I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office re-watch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello everybody. There is a new paper company in town. Michael Scott Paper Company.
Holy moly. We're going to talk about it today. However, I have to say this before we get started. What? We look gorgeous today. You all should know. I don't know what this podcast is going to be today, but we look hot. Well, Jenna has that like dark, smoky eyeliner.
I did a smoky eye today. How do you even do that? I need a tutorial. Oh, multiple YouTube tutorials is how we got this smoky eye today. I did super straight hair. You look amazing. You look like you're about to take over like multiple corporations. I am wearing a blazer.
I know. I guess we have to say that because people can't see us, but we look amazing. Angela, your nails look incredible. I mean, details. We have details. We look good, guys. We're feeling it today. We cannot wait to talk about this episode.
And then we have a photo shoot. Jenna, who are we? What is happening? We're a big deal. I don't know. Will you tell my kids that next time we're at Target? Hey, hey. Big deal over there in the seasonal aisle.
Yeah. And you can only pick one of those things. Pick one. You're not getting all three. Let's get to talking about what we're here for. It's season five, episode 23, written by the amazing Justin Spitzer and directed by Jean Stupnitsky. He's the credited director on this one, but he actually had a partner.
This episode was co-directed by Jean Stupnitsky and his longtime writing partner, Lee Eisenberg. That's right. They would go on to direct many more episodes together of The Office. They shared a little bit in the commentary that they would rotate who would take credit. It sort of went along some DGA rules at the time. So Jean got credit for this one, but they were both there together every day. So we want to give Leah a shout out. And the next time there's an episode up that says Lee directed, know that Jean was right
there by his side. And we reached out to both of them, and they shared a ton of great details for this episode. So I'm very, very excited. Here's your summary. Michael, Pam, and Ryan are in their new office. They're struggling to adjust. It's a very tiny, intimate work environment. Very tiny.
Can I tell you one thing? Justin said they even considered finding a smaller room. What? Can you imagine? I can't because I was there and I know how almost impossible it was to shoot in that room. With like the camera operators, the sound department, you guys? Smaller room. That's bonkers to me.
Well, upstairs in Dunder Mifflin, there is a new receptionist in town. A new lady named Kelly Erin Hannon. Dwight and Andy are both kind of crushing on her, but they also have this new friendship. So this crush is going to really challenge their new bond. In the meantime, Jim is trying to figure out what the heck is a rundown? What is a rundown? Poor guy. And let's not forget there's going to be some giant square pancakes.
Yeah. Lady, I forgot that they were big squares. I have details on that. You do? I can't wait. All right. I have some pancake details. I can't wait.
Let's get into some fast facts. All right. Here's a mini fast fact. This episode actually aired the same night as Dream Team. In between these two episodes, they ran the very first episode of Parks and Recreation. How about that? We were like a little sandwich. We were.
And we were the bread in Parks and Recreation was the... Bologna. The cheese. Cheese. Sounds like a dig. We don't mean it. No, I didn't mean it to be. I had a bologna sandwich every day in my lunch growing up.
No, but it's, you know, saying something is bologna or something is cheese. It seems like a dig, but... They were the meat. Well, now that seems like a dig on the bread. The bread isn't important. Well, the bread's the best part. That's just because I love bread. Okay.
We'll leave this analogy. There you have it. It was Office Parks and Rec Office. Yes. Fast fact number one, I thought we should talk a little bit about this teeny tiny space of Michael Scott Paper Company, this 165 square foot office with no windows on the bottom floor of Dundarmiflin. With a exposed shower in the corner?
Yes. Correct. Now that was a fakie shower. Oh. That was a design by our set designer, Michael Gallenberg. Because there was a real shower down there. I had to use it one time, not in that room, across the hallway. There was an office that had a tiny shower.
Really? Yes. Why did you have to use it? Okay. Well, do you remember the summer my hair turned green? Yep. You could really see it on camera. Guys, I spent the whole summer swimming with the kids in the pool and my hair turned green.
It happens to the blondies out there. And Kim put this thing on my hair to like kind of tint it, you know? To get the green out? To get the green out. And I had to wash it out of my hair. Like you put it on and then I had to rinse it out and then she had to blow dry my hair. Okay. Now why didn't they just use the little sink in the hair and makeup trailer or the shower
in your trailer? Because the sink in the hair and makeup trailer, first of all, it didn't get hot. And Kim was a little concerned because the water is like this sort of recycled water. Yeah. That it would strip the color off my hair that she was trying to put in. Now that you say that, I know that because there have been times when I've needed to shower off. Your trailers have a shower, but it is exactly that.
It's like a tank of weird sort of chemically treated water. Right. So that it can stay in the tank and then not be poisonous. Yeah. And it doesn't get very hot. And also I've had people tell me not to use it. I sort of was like, maybe just get rid of the showers in the trailers. Yeah, put in a closet.
They're taking up space. You'll need a closet. Always need more closet. I mean, it's part of my life mantra. Can I have more closets? Well, you need closets for your baskets, lady. Your basket collection. Give me all the baskets.
Well, listen, this little room, it was located in our writer's building. It was on the bottom floor and it was an actual storage closet. It was not a set. So the walls did not move. They talked about should we build Michael Scott paper company in the warehouse. That was my thought where we've built many a set. No, for whatever reason they crammed us into the post production storage room where previous to us shooting in there, they had stored thousands of hours of archive tape of our show.
This was back in the day and we just had walls and walls of five seasons of tape on our show. They had to relocate all the tapes. They had to redress the room. I said the shower is fake, but those pipes were real. There really were these giant pipes. Yes, the big black pipes that were coming out. Those were real. Yes.
Also the bathrooms that are outside in the hallway, the two doors on either side of the Michael Scott paper company door, those bathrooms were real. Those were the actual working bathrooms for anybody who worked on the bottom floor. Those were the bathrooms we would use in between scenes when we filmed in the warehouse. Yes, are in that hallway by the editing bay. Right across from us were our two editors, Claire and Dave. And above us were the writer's offices. So we were over in that building with the writers.
Also in this building is the lobby area that leads out into the parking lot. This room also gets repurposed for Cafe Disco. Yes, we went back down there for that. So those are all my details on that room. I'll have more to share as we break down the episode. More little quirks of working in there. Yeah, you spent a lot of time in there. We did.
Are you ready for fast fact number two? I am. Remember last week when I told you that Michael sent a letter to everybody through NBC.com. Yes. Announcing his new paper company. Well, this week he unveiled his website. And NBC created a Michael Scott paper company website and it had photos of the room. It was basically the same room taken from three different angles.
It had the downloadable coupon that is shown in this episode. You know, the one that promises unparalleled customer service. Yep. That Pam and Ryan refused to copy. And it also had the mission statement for Michael Scott paper company. Yes, it did. And we reached out to Joya. You know, we've talked about Joya before.
She was in charge of all the digital content for the office that was on NBC.com. She shared with us what the mission statement said. Here it is. It's the Michael Scott paper company's mission to provide you the highest quality paper. The best possible service at the lowest possible prices. Sounds good. Just wait. There's more.
This paper business is more than just paper. More than just a business. It's about establishing quality human relationships with our clients. While little Timmy wakes up in the middle of the night with whooping cough and you need someone to call, we'll be there. When sweet Christine gets stood up by her prom date, we'll be there. When the dam breaks in your backyard and the only thing that can stop the flow of water from flooding your house is a ream of paper, we'll be there. At the Michael Scott paper company, we'll always be there through thick and thin in sickness and health till death or retirement do us part. We'll be there.
For a while, it's just pretty standard. Kind of boilerplate. Yeah. Yeah. But I really like it when he says we're more than just a business. We're about quality human relationships with our clients. I'm like, oh. And then it goes off into some very specific examples of when you might be there for me.
But in the end, I liked it. I think I was a little curious about what kind of backyard you have that has a dam. Well, listen, we'll be there. Fast fact number three, Ellie Kemper is our new receptionist. Woohoo. We love Ellie. We are definitely going to have her on the show. You know, Ellie and I both grew up in St. Louis.
I know. Now I did not know her growing up. She is six years younger than me. I had actually graduated college and moved to Los Angeles while she was still in high school. I'm six years older than my husband. So you just described our relationship, I guess. Had we known each other back then. By the way, do you know who her high school drama teacher was?
Ellie's? No. John Hamm. Shut the front door. John Hamm also grew up in St. Louis. I also did not know John Hamm growing up, even though we were closer in age. I can't believe that was Ellie's drama teacher. Yeah. But of course, you know, Phyllis was also from St. Louis.
Yes. Our director Ken Quapas was from St. Louis. And our first lady, Rusty Mahmood was from St. Louis. So we were all very excited. Well, you know, on the DVD commentary, there was a little bit of chatter. On the DVD was Jenna, Jean, and Lee, and Justin. Nice group. Nice group.
There was a little bit of chatter about which city in America was most represented in the cast and crew of The Office. I think with the addition of Ellie, it became St. Louis. It was Boston. It became St. Louis. Yes. And Jenna, I want you to know, you have clearly been a... This is going to make me laugh, obsessed with facts for a long time. I want you to hear what you brought to the DVD commentary.
RAD is also from St. Louis. And so is Shannon, one of our PAs, and Ken Quapas, one of our directors. See, you said you were not going to have any fun facts. Now you're just pulling them out. So many people are having so much fun with my facts. Oh my God. And by the way, I forgot about Shannon, who was also from St. Louis. I know.
Well, you listed them all. I sort of just took a snippet out. You sort of talked for a while about St. Louis. But clearly you went into this DVD commentary saying, guys, I hope I have some fun facts. So much so that they were like, you do have great facts. It just cracked me up to hear you talking about your fun facts, and now you have your fast facts. I'll tell you what. When I would go into DVD commentaries, I was often worried that I wouldn't have anything to talk about.
So I would do kind of the equivalent of a mini deep dive on something. I wanted to come in with like an interesting tidbit that we could throw in there if there was ever a moment where we weren't covering something about the show. This is why I love you. It goes back so far. It does, but it just got me so tickled. We had a fan question from KJ Davy. Aaron is my favorite character of the office. How did the producers come up with her personality and her character as a whole? And how much creative liberty did Ellie have in creating her character's quirks and traits?
KJ, Jean told me something crazy about the development of the character of Kelly Aaron. He said that the writers had not fully fleshed out Aaron's personality by the time we started shooting. So when we started, they had Ellie perform all of her scenes and all of her talking heads two different ways as two different characters. I remember this. She had to do them in like that earnest quirky way that we know and love as Aaron. That's the one we eventually go with. But Jean said, believe it or not, there exists a bizarro Aaron where her lines are also delivered in a no nonsense way. And I asked him, how long did she have to do this before they decided?
And he said they definitely had like two totally different versions of her talking heads written. And then in her scenes with Dwight and Andy hitting on her, she had to then perform those with different characteristics. I mean, Jean said he gives her so much credit because this was her first big role on a TV show. And she basically did two versions of Aaron in every scene for the entire week. So until you shared about that sort of two versions of Aaron, I had forgotten about it. But now there's a deleted scene that makes sense to me. Aaron just looks at camera, you know, she's doing a talking head and she's just like, do I have to do one of these on all of my breaks? Yes, Angela.
James Carey had the candy bag for this episode and it included Aaron's two talking heads, neither of which end up in the episode. Well, one of them is on the DVD. Okay, this is the one that was in the candy bag as their first choice, which was, it's pretty cool. Like any other office, I guess, phones, computers, copiers, do I have to do this on all my breaks? Yeah. Is that the one that's included? Yeah, and I was a little confused because I thought it felt sort of off. Then they had this must shoot alternate, which went like this.
Most places you go, the chairs are really crappy and you're uncomfortable all day. My chair here is great. I really hope this works out. And that was like the one that quirky Aaron would say. Yeah, I guess that's our sign that the office got the new chairs because she's loving Pam's chair. That's it. I think Pam finally got her new chair and now she's working down in Michael Scott paper company. Pam talks about the chairs too later on.
I know. I just want to say that this doing two versions of your character happened to me on the film Blades of Glory. Really? Yeah. I had gone in with this idea for this version of the character that was based kind of on like Bernadette Peters' performance and the jerk. Yeah. I just really loved her wide-eyed, innocent, earnest approach to love and sex and just sort of all of it. Being with sort of an oddball guy and that is very similar to my character of Katie in Blades of Glory.
But I think there was a little bit of concern that that might feel like too big of a choice. And so they also had me do all the scenes just pretty straight. And I did that for a couple of days. Every scene. And eventually they went with my quirky version. I was so proud. But it was super intense because I remember one day. I was shooting the scene with Will Arnett and Amy Poehler.
They played a brother-sister ice skating duo and their little sister slash assistant. Oh my God. It was so much fun shooting with those guys. That whole movie looked like a blast. The cast looked like so much fun. We had a blast. But we had this scene and they were like, okay, we're going to lunch. Jenna, you get two takes.
One in one version and one in the other. And I had to just nail both versions. And I remember someone and I can't remember who came up to me early and they were like, just don't do a good job of the version you don't want to have them pick. Just do the version you like really well. Take one of them. Yeah. And then they'll be forced to go with, you know, your vision of the character.
I couldn't do it. My like actor integrity. No, just your whole little compass. You couldn't ever do that. Yeah, I couldn't do it. It is interesting to me how characters become like who they are on a show or in a movie. This is reminding me of a project that one of my friends wrote. It was based on a real life story from her life.
And she had this character of a guy named Ed and he was based on her friend in real life Ed. And Ed was also an actor. So Ed went into audition for Ed. So he's in front of the network and he's like, hi, I'm Ed. I'm reading for Ed. And he just was himself. She wrote him as himself. We were all like, Ed's going to get the part of Ed, right?
I mean, they wrote it for Ed. And he didn't get it. I was like, how can Ed not get Ed? It's based on Ed. Like what? Lady, I have a very similar story. Okay. I auditioned for this lead role in a pilot opposite Dan Finnerty.
He's from the Dan band. Yeah. Yeah. It was hilarious. And when I read the role, I thought to myself, oh, this is so Maryland right. And so I went in and I just did my best impression of Mary Lynn. I love Mary Lynn. I know.
I have worked with her many times. I super copied her. I get to the final audition. It's me and two other women. One of them is like a tall, gorgeous blonde. The other one is Mary Lynn rice. Then I find out that Dan knows Mary Lynn and he wrote the role for her. And he won.
Well, I was proud of myself because I was like, well, I guess I nailed it on what he was going for. He was going for Mary Lynn. Did Mary Lynn get it? No, neither of us did. They gave it to the blonde. Oh, no. I know.
And it was so funny because I thought to myself, well, obviously they're going to go with Mary Lynn. They're not going to go with me. I'm copying her. Right. They didn't give it to either of us. But the two of us. I don't know.
They were at least doing what he intended when he wrote it. Yeah. No, they went the other way. You never know. You never know. Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we will really get into this episode. I have a lot of fun stuff this week, I think.
Me too. I have some sunglasses information. Hold up. I have sunglasses information. Oh my God. What if we have the same sunglasses information? What if we have the same sunglasses information? Whose sunglasses are you going to talk about?
Two different people's sunglasses. I have photo evidence of somebody's sunglasses. I have photo evidence of somebody's sunglasses. This is how you guys know that we don't talk to each other. We show up and try to surprise each other. And sometimes we find the same things. We'll be back. We are back.
And this episode opens with Michael driving up in his convertible. He's got the top down. He's blasting his music. Yeah. It's Britney, bitch. But it's Lady Gaga. Exactly. Yeah.
It's Lady Gaga singing Just Dance. But it's Britney, bitch. At 18 seconds, I caught the camera crew in Michael's sunglasses. You did? Yep. Go to 18 seconds. You can see our camera crew in his sunglasses. You guys, there was some debate about Michael's sunglasses.
We're already into the sunglasses info. I know. It's right out of the gate. They couldn't decide. Two things. One, should he leave the sunglasses on the whole time? Mm-hmm. Or should he take them off?
Okay. They decided it's better for comedy if your sunglasses are off because you use your face, you guys. Okay. Right? Number two, they were trying to debate between the pair of sunglasses they picked or a pair that were really popular at the time that P. Diddy was wearing. Oh.
Okay. And they picked not P. Diddy's glasses. That's right. So they picked not P. Diddy's glasses, but to also take them off for the sake of comedy. Well, at 32 seconds, Michael is going to try to parallel park. He's going to do this unsuccessfully. There's just not enough room. I love when he said not going to make this one.
There's like three car lengths of curb available. Randy Cordray told us that we did this in cuts. So first they padded the rear bumper of Michael's PT cruiser so that it wouldn't actually damage the car behind him. They shot it in a way so you can't see the padding. When Michael pulls away, they had removed the foam cushioning and that crunch you hear was a special effects sound that they added in post. Well, I thought it was a really relatable moment because I know I've bailed mid-parallel
park before, especially if you're trying to parallel park somewhere where people are like eating outside. And they're watching you. They're all watching you do that. Eat, eat, eat, eat. Like trying to back in and then you're just like, forget it. Bailing. When I went to take my driving test, I was about to fail.
The last task was parallel park. Same. And I nailed it and I passed my driving test. Gina, same here. I was doing horribly, but Coach Wolf, who taught me driver's ed, had really worked with me on parallel parking. My dad had really worked with me on parallel parking. Does this make us sound like bad drivers that parallel parking saved us?
Well, here's the thing. Ironically, I do not get in actual car accidents, but I am constantly hitting things when I'm trying to park. I know. I've seen you like get real close to hitting something when you were parking one time. I was like, Jenna, Jenna, Jenna. Yeah. Well, when I took my driver's ed test, the tester guy, he wrote a little note on my
test score. What did it say? Very distracted. Distracted? Because when he was giving me my driver's ed test, we drove down the little main street of the small town I'm from. And my friends were all hanging out at this car wash that had gone out of business. People would park their cars there and hang out.
Sure. Like teenagers. And a bunch of my friends were parked there and they all knew I was taking my test. And so as I drove by, I honked and waved. And my tester guy did not like that. But you still passed. I still passed because of parallel parking. Well, also arriving this morning to the Scranton Business Park is Ryan and Jim and Pam are
walking in. Pam and her blazer and her new plant alert. I know. People wrote in about the plant, Angela. It's the first thing I noticed. 42 seconds. Spotted a potted plant is what I wrote in my notes. And it's very cute.
And it's going to stay on the little desk in Michael Scott Paper Company. Well, for a long time, we've wondered who would bring in the potted plants at reception. I guess this solves it. It was Pam. It was Pam. While Pam and Jim are walking into the parking lot, Michael has wedged his car between two other cars. And he's trying to shimmy out.
Over the back, holding the Cheetos, by the way. Yes. Jenna, Steve ripped his pants in the scene. He did. Yeah. He was trying to scooch over the back of the PT Cruiser. And his pants got hung up on the back of the little convertible part. And he's scooching.
It's in the bloopers. And I was going to play it, but the majority of the bloopers is Steve scooching and grunting, trying to get over the back hump of the car. And he finally says, I'm going to need a new pair of pants. It just made me laugh. You know what? I'll put the blooper in our stories because it's really one you have to watch to appreciate. Now we go to our opening credits.
And they are all new this episode in honor of Michael Scott Paper Company. I was very excited for you. I was like, oh, I bet Jenna has a whole breakdown because you've done a whole thing about the opening credits. First of all, I did not remember this. So when this came on, I was so delighted. And then all the memories came flooding back of us filming these new opening credits. They were also not in the script.
This was Mindy Kaling's idea. Lee and Jean said they absolutely loved getting to shoot them. And they really tried to match the tone and style of the original main titles. So I did a whole breakdown of the Michael Scott Paper Company main titles and our usual main titles. And they match up almost shot for shot. It's pretty cool. That's awesome. I have some fun tidbits about some of the things we saw in those opening credits.
OK. First of all, the goldfish on Michael's desk. Oh, yeah. This all happens about one minute, 18 seconds, right? There's a great overview of the whole room. We got a fan mail flurry about this goldfish lady. Oh, yeah. Remember last week we talked about the Jerry Maguire goldfish and how Michael and Pam had their Jerry Maguire moment?
Well, Michael is going to have a goldfish on his desk now. But fan mail flurry points out that there is going to be a different goldfish every time we cut to a shot of Michael's desk. And there is a reason for that. Randy Cordray said this was an Easter egg that they planted in these episodes. It's never talked about. But the idea was that Michael could not keep this fish alive. Randy told me that every Friday they would give the goldfish to a crew member who wanted it. And then they would replace it with a new fish for the next episode.
So moving forward, folks, I will track the fish. It starts as your standard orange goldfish. OK. Goldfish tracker. Next up, I would really like to talk about the stapler that BJ is using in the opening credits. It is a paper pro stapler, and we were obsessed with it in Michael Scott Paper Company. Obsessed. Why?
It is the greatest stapler you will ever use ever. Phil Shea, let me keep one. I still have it. You do not have to push on it the way BJ is in the opening credits. He is operating the stapler incorrectly. You just give it a little squeeze, and the air pressure, some sort of mechanism, makes it staple perfectly. I looked it up. Here's how it is described.
OK. The paper pro is the first engineering breakthrough in staplers since, well, the stapler. Push it with one finger's worth of effort, and a spring-loaded mechanism drives the staple with 30 pounds of force through up to 20 sheets of paper. Wow. We loved that stapler. We loved it. Of all the things I thought we would talk about today, I did not think we'd talk about a super air pressure powered stapler. I recommend it.
I'm dying to use one. Finally, the copier that you see in the opening credits and throughout this episode is the broken copier from the surplus. I love that written on the side that says trash. I know. That copier is just haunting Pam. She's lost her comfortable chair, and now she's back with this horrible copier. What has she done to her life? You know that was sitting out by the dumpsters.
They wrote trash on it and set it out. So right at the beginning of their first day of the Michael Scott paper company, there would have been a series of talking heads. Ryan had one. Michael had one. Pam had one about her first day. I thought it was really sweet and also made me a little curious. I think we need to hear it. I'm embarking on a new adventure.
There was a fork in the road, and I took the road less traveled. Never traveled. Not even a road, really. More of a path with a sign that says those who pass shall die and a skull and crossbones. The other road was kind of like Putnam Road. That's a really boring road in Scranton. So these were the two paths that you were choosing between. But guys, in Scranton, I Google image Putnam Road.
It looks like a fine road. There's something crazy. I worked at Putnam Investments as an executive secretary for years. That was my last full-time job I had as an executive assistant before I was able to earn my living full-time as an actor. Woo! Yeah, that's a full circle life moment. Well, back upstairs, you know, there's such a funny scene. Kelly is sort of leaning up on Jim's desk and she's just sort of mumbling things. Like, you're where you're not really talking to me.
看起来是条不错的路。有些地方太疯狂了。我在普特曼投资公司（Putnam Investments）当了多年执行秘书。那是我在能够以演员为生之前，作为执行助理干的最后一份全职工作。哇！太棒了，那是人生圆满的时刻。嗯，回到楼上，你知道，有个很好笑的场景。凯莉有点靠在吉姆的桌子上，嘴里嘟囔着一些事情。比如，你根本不是在跟我说话。
She is just waiting for Charles to say Kelly. And then she runs in and she's like, you wanted me? And he's like, no, no, no, I meant that Kelly. And this is when we meet Aaron. Yes. Jim has this fantastic talking head that he says that Kelly thinks if she says you wanted me enough that Charles will in fact want her. It's not the worst plan she's ever had. Hey, this made me think. Like, this is like self-fulfilling prophecy.
她只是在等查尔斯叫“凯莉”。然后她跑进去说，你找我吗？而查尔斯却说，不，不，不，我是指那个凯莉。这就是我们见到艾琳的时候。是的。吉姆有个精彩的单人访谈，他说凯莉觉得只要自己说“你够想要我吗”，查尔斯就会真的想要她。这可不是她有过的最糟糕的计划。嘿，这让我想到了。这就像是自我实现的预言。
Like, Kelly is using self-fulfilling prophecy. My mom used to have this saying, and I think it's like paraphrasing scripture and proverbs, but speak of what is not as if it were so and it shall become. And I think I was like sort of in a very deep place when I was watching this episode. I had some things in my life that I had sort of written out like something I was meditating about, praying about, and it was coming to fruition and I was trying to plant these seeds of like positive good intention, right? To then have this great harvest of this good thing. And when you watch the office through that filter, you're like, Kelly, Kelly is practicing self-fulfilling prophecy.
就像凯莉在运用自我实现预言。我妈妈以前常说一句话，我想那是对经文和箴言的意译，但要“称无为有，事情就会成就”。我想我当时看这一集时，内心处于一种很深的境界。我生活中的一些事情，我曾写下来过，比如我在冥想、祈祷的事情，它们正在实现，我试图播下积极美好意愿的种子，对吧？然后收获这些美好事物的伟大收成。当你通过这个滤镜看《办公室》时，你会想，凯莉，凯莉在实践自我实现预言。
It's great. I use that all the time. We talk about that. Yeah. And just in the formation of this podcast, we must have said what we wanted for two years. Yeah. Before we developed the show and signed a contract. Speak the positive. Speak it. I always say when you blow out your birthday candles, you should tell everyone your wish because the more people who know, there's more people invested in helping you make it come true.
太棒了。我一直在用这个。我们经常谈论这个。是的。而且就在这个播客的筹备过程中，我们肯定把我们想要的东西说两年了。是的。在我们开发节目并签约之前。说出积极的话。大声说出来。我总是说，当你吹灭生日蜡烛时，你应该把你的愿望告诉所有人，因为知道的人越多，就有越多的人投入到帮助你实现愿望中。
Yeah. Share your wishes. Share it. I love that. I had to share that. Well, I have got a bit of a bombshell regarding this scene. What? A full bombshell. What? So, you know, Charles says, I wasn't talking about you, Kelly. I was talking about the other Kelly
是的。分享你的愿望。说出来。我太喜欢了。我不得不分享这个。好吧，关于这个场景，我有个重磅消息要爆料。什么？绝对重磅。什么？所以，你知道，查尔斯说，我不是在对你说话，凯莉。我说的是另一个凯莉。
and they eventually settle on the fact that they will call the second Kelly by her middle name, Aaron. Yeah. The original name for Ellie's character, the one that appears in the table draft. What? Was not Kelly. It was not Aaron. Her name was Mary. Mary? Yeah.
他们最终决定把第二个凯莉叫她的中间名——艾琳。是的。艾莉这个角色的原名，也就是出现在剧本初稿里的那个。什么？不是凯莉。也不是艾琳。她的名字叫玛丽。玛丽？是的。
And this scene was not a thing where they have the same name. That was a late addition. Oh, wow. I love this scene. I know me too. Well, fan question from Kelly Ann M. Who says, we need to track Aaron's hair progression. When did she go red? She will eventually win Cutis Redhead in the office, but she's a brunette here.
而且这个场景本来没有同名这个设定。那是后来加的。哦，哇。我很喜欢这个场景。我知道，我也是。好吧，来自凯莉·安·M的粉丝提问。她说，我们需要追踪艾琳的发型变化。她是什么时候染红发的？她最终会在《办公室》里赢得“柯蒂斯红发女郎”的称号，但她在这里是个棕发女郎。
We need to track it. Well, Lee Eisenberg filled me in on this. Well, I remember some of this. He said when Ellie showed up for her very first day of work, her hair color was almost identical to mine. Yep. And everyone freaked out. They were not trying to tell a story that Pam was being replaced by a sort of lookalike person. And they were really worried that if they put her on camera, having the same color hair,
我们需要追踪一下。好吧，李·艾森伯格把这事告诉我了。好吧，我记得一些。他说当艾莉来上班的第一天时，她的发色和我的几乎一模一样。没错。然后大家都吓坏了。他们可不想讲一个帕姆被某个长相相似的人取代的故事。他们真的很担心如果把她拍进镜头里，顶着相同颜色的头发，
that it was going to tell a story they weren't telling. Yeah. So they had to change the whole schedule for the day and color her hair. I was in the hair and makeup trailer when she was getting her hair colored by Kim Ferry. And I guess Kim just has a drawer of hair color. Sure. And they came up with this sort of brunette color, which will now evolve. The character of Aaron was also not originally meant to become a full-time regular character.
这会传达一个他们并不想讲的故事。是的。所以他们不得不改变当天的整个日程，给她的头发重新上色。当金·费瑞给她染发时，我就在发型和化妆房里。我猜金抽屉里备有各种发色。当然。他们想出了这种棕色，以后还会演变。艾琳这个角色原本也没打算成为常驻全职角色。
This was just going to be a few episodes. So we will track it. But I believe her hair is going to get to sort of change over to that red color as they make her a more permanent character on the show. Yeah. I remember that day and Ellie is such a team player, you know? My memory is correct. They dyed it one time and then dyed it again. Oh boy.
这本来只是客串几集。所以我们会追踪的。但我相信随着她成为剧中更长久的角色，她的发色会逐渐变成那种红色。是的。我记得那一天，艾莉真的是个极好的团队合作者，你知道吗？如果我的记忆没错的话。他们染了一次，然后又染了一次。哦，天哪。
Yeah. Oh boy. Michael Scott Paper Company has kind of come already to a standstill. They don't know what to do. They're like, what do we do now? They're just sitting there looking at each other. Yeah. Michael's working on his evite for his pancake luncheon.
是的。哦，天哪。迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司已经陷入停滞了。他们不知道该怎么办。他们就像是，我们现在该怎么办？他们只是坐在那里大眼瞪小眼。是的。迈克尔正在为他的煎饼午宴制作电子邀请函。
We had a fan catch from Rhea V and Abby M who noticed if you look closely, it says that the luncheon is going to take place on Saturday. I saw that too. Also during this scene, you can hear the sounds of toilets flushing through the pipes overhead. You're really getting a sense of this workspace. So we could actually hear toilets flushing if somebody used the real bathrooms outside. So while we were shooting, they would not allow anyone in there. But while we rehearsed or while we were waiting to shoot, people could use the bathrooms. And so we would really sit in that room and hear flushing toilets.
我们收到了来自蕾亚·V和艾比·M的粉丝捉虫，他们注意到如果你仔细看，上面写着午宴将在星期六举行。我也看到了。此外，在这个场景中，你可以听到头顶管道传来的冲水声。你对这个办公空间真是有了深刻的体会。所以如果有谁使用了外面真正的洗手间，我们实际上能听到冲水声。所以在我们拍摄时，他们不允许任何人进去。但在我们排练或等待拍摄时，人们可以使用洗手间。所以我们确实会坐在那个房间里听到冲水声。
And I also don't know if you noticed the spots that BJ and I are sitting in when we first walked into that room. Our natural inclination was to sit across from one another at the table because it gave you maximum space for your elbows. Sure. You know, but you couldn't shoot us that way. We had to both sort of sit with our backs like scrunched up against that wall kind of next to each other facing Michael. Because it was literally the only way to get us on camera. Last week in Dream Team for the DVD commentary for that episode, Matt Zone actually talked about this episode and how hard it was to shoot in that room because of the angles.
我也不知道你们有没有注意到，我和BJ刚走进那个房间时坐的位置。我们的自然倾向是坐在桌子的两侧对坐，因为这能为你的手肘提供最大的空间。当然。你知道的，但那样拍不了我们。我们俩都得背部紧贴着那堵墙，有点挨着彼此，面对着迈克尔坐着。因为这字面意思上是把我们拍进镜头的唯一方法。上周在针对那一集的DVD评论音轨中，马特·佐恩实际上谈到了这一集，以及因为角度问题在那个房间里拍摄有多么困难。
Exactly what you were talking about. They kept catching each other. Our two camera operators kept catching each other in the shot. So they had to sort of position you guys so that they could get these single camera shots of you. Yeah, I think that's something you don't think about when you watch the scene is how there's all these extra people in the room. Yeah. But they're magically avoiding one another on camera. But at the same time, Steve is Michael can't walk from his desk to the poker table without bonking his leg into things.
这正是你刚才说的。他们总是拍到彼此。我们的两个摄像师总是在镜头里拍到对方。所以他们不得不把你们摆在那个位置，这样才能拍到你们的单人镜头。是的，我想这是你看这一幕时不会去想的事情，那就是房间里有这么多额外的人。是的。但他们在镜头前神奇地避开了彼此。但与此同时，史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔从他的办公桌走到扑克桌前，腿不撞到东西是走不过去的。
You know, it's like that tight. Well, now Michael is going to ask Pam to make 800 copies of his unparalleled customer service coupon. But Pam has a talking head and I really relate to this. She says, if I make this one copy, then I'll become the girl who makes copies and then I'm basically a receptionist again. And I don't know if you noticed where the phone was on that table, but it is right in front of Pam. So she's already clearly closest to the phone. And even later when it rings, Michael says, answer it. I know.
你知道，就是这么挤。好了，现在迈克尔要让帕姆复印800份他那无与伦比的客户服务优惠券。但帕姆有一段单人访谈，我对此深有共鸣。她说，如果我做了这一份复印，那么我就会变成那个专门复印的女孩，然后我基本上又成了一个前台。我不知道你们有没有注意到那个电话在桌子的什么位置，它就在帕姆的正前方。所以很明显她本来就离电话最近。甚至后来电话铃响时，迈克尔还说，接电话。我知道。
Right? Yeah. She's really trying to break out of this role of receptionist and she refuses to make the copy. She doesn't want to go down Putnam Road, guys. She doesn't. She wants the other path, the more exciting path. Well, it's a pretty big day for a few other characters at Dunder Mifflin. Dwight is going to take Andy hunting.
对吧？是的。她真的在试图摆脱前台这个角色，她拒绝复印。她不想走普特曼路，伙计们。她不想。她想要另一条路，更令人兴奋的路。好吧，对于邓德米弗林的几个其他角色来说，这算是个相当重大的日子。德怀特要带安迪去打猎。
They're like buddy buddy. There's so much more of this scene where they're sort of wrestling and like doing all this stuff. It goes on for so long. I have no doubt. You not ask the fellas to roughhouse or wrestle in a scene unless you want to have an hour of additional footage of it. Because anytime they had Rainn Wilson and John Krasinski have to do something like that, like last week's knock knock joke thing. Any scuffle. It's worth a watch in the deleted scenes because those two fellas go for so long and all their fake different ways of attacking each other.
他们好得像哥们儿一样。这个场景还有很多内容，他们一直在摔跤什么的。持续了太久。毫无疑问。千万别让小伙子们在戏里打闹或摔跤，除非你想多出一个小时的素材。因为每当他们让雷恩·威尔逊和约翰·卡拉辛斯基拍这种戏时，就像上周的敲门笑话那样。任何打闹。在被删减片段里都很值得一看，因为这两个小伙子能折腾好久，还有他们各种假装攻击对方的方式。
And they get so into John's personal space and his face is hilarious. I don't know how he kept a straight face. Andy had a talking head that was deleted where he talks about this bromance. You know, we see Dwights in the episode, but Andy had a counterpart one and I think we need to hear it. No. Let me tell you something. When Angela and I split, I went through it big time, lost my high notes. Top of my range was like...
而且他们靠约翰的个人空间靠得太近了，他的表情太搞笑了。我不知道他是怎么忍住不笑的。安迪有一个被删掉的单人访谈，他在里面谈到了这段兄弟情。你知道，我们在正片里看到了德怀特的访谈，但安迪也有个对应的，我觉得我们得听听。不。我告诉你们一件事。当安娜和我分手时，我经历了一段非常痛苦的时期，高音都唱不上去了。我音域的上限就像……
Then it took some time. I got my heel on. I got some perspective on. And I found a new friend in the most unlikely of places. The enemy bend. And now... Wow. He got his high notes back.
然后花了一些时间。我恢复状态了。我调整好了心态。并在最意想不到的地方找到了新朋友。死敌。现在……哇。他找回高音了。
He did. He got his heel on. He got his perspective on. And he found it all on the enemy bend. I know. I also really love the storyline of Charles asking Jim for the rundown. Yes. And Jim has no idea.
他确实找回了。他状态恢复了。他调整好心态了。而且这一切都是在死敌那里找到的。我知道。我也很喜欢查尔斯向吉姆要汇报总结（rundown）的这条故事线。是的。而吉姆根本不知道。
What a rundown is. And he's not going to ask. He's too afraid. I know. So when we reached out to Jean and Lee, they said that this whole rundown story was a late addition. It was part of a rewrite session. And you know, we've talked about how some of the writers would break off into these little pods. So Paul Lieberstein, Jen Salata and BJ Novak broke away from the group.
什么是汇报总结。而且他不好意思问。他太害怕了。我知道。所以当我们联系简和李时，他们说整个汇报总结的故事线是后来加的。这是剧本重写会议的一部分。你知道的，我们之前聊过，有些编剧会分成这样的小组。所以保尔·李伯斯坦、珍·萨拉塔和BJ·诺瓦克脱离了集体。
And in about two hours, they came up with this whole rundown storyline. I love it. I know. And then Justin Spitzer said, they thought this was great. This sort of rundown was sort of this vague term. And no one in the writer's room really knew what it meant. So they thought, well, that's perfect. Maybe Jim wouldn't know either.
在大约两个小时内，他们想出了整个汇报总结的故事线。我太喜欢了。我知道。然后贾斯汀·斯皮策说，他们觉得这太棒了。这种汇报总结有点像是个含糊不清的词。编剧室里没有人真正知道它是什么意思。所以他们想，嗯，这太完美了。也许吉姆也不知道。
And they said after the episode aired that they got mail that people were like, yeah, a rundown. Yeah, rundown. Like people had heard of it. And they were like, no way. So I looked it up. I googled because we're ladies that Google. We are. I just wrote, what is a rundown?
他们说在这一集播出后，他们收到了邮件，人们说，哦，对，汇报总结。对，汇报总结。就像人们都听说过这东西一样。而他们当时就想，不可能吧。所以我查了一下。我谷歌了一下，因为我们是爱谷歌的女士。我们是。我只写了，什么是汇报总结？
And this is what the internet had to say. Okay. In businesses, a rundown is a status report or summary. Yeah. I mean, common sense would lead me in that direction. If I had to guess, I would think, oh, I should make a list of all my current clients and their status. Yeah. I think I could have been a little confused.
这就是互联网给出的答案。好吧。在商业中，汇报总结是状态报告或总结。是的。我是说，常识就会引导我朝这个方向想。如果让我猜，我会想，哦，我应该列出我目前所有的客户以及他们的状态。是的。我想我可能会有点困惑。
Like, is a rundown my sales? Is it like an item I sing of how much product I move? Or is it more just my client's names and how long they've been my clients? You know, I think there is a little bit of vagueness, like Justin said. But Jim just needs to ask, what do you want a rundown of? My clients, the inventory? What exactly? Sales.
比如，汇报总结是我的销售额吗？是我处理了多少产品的统计项？还是更偏向于我的客户的名字以及他们成为我客户多久了？你知道，我觉得确实有点含糊，就像贾斯汀说的。但吉姆只需要问，你想要什么的汇报总结？我的客户，还是库存？具体是什么？销售额。
Sales? Well, I'll tell you what. We got a lot of mail on this. And Hannah Q. had a strong opinion. Oh. Saying, forgive me for saying this, but I think I'm on Charles' side when it comes to the rundown. I've never had an office job, and even I have a pretty clear idea of what it could or should look like. Come on, Jim.
销售额？好吧，我跟你们说。我们收到了很多关于这个的邮件。汉娜·Q对此有强烈的观点。哦。她说，请原谅我这么说，但在汇报总结这件事上，我想我站在查尔斯这边。我从来没做过办公室工作，即便如此，对于它看起来可能或应该是怎样的，我也有一张相当清晰的画面。拜托，吉姆。
You're a smart guy. Look within and find the rundown. Hannah's not having it. She's not having it. Meanwhile, in the kitchen, we're going to kick off this storyline where Dwight and Andy are both kind of flirting with Aaron. Dwight does this weird thing where he teases her about the office being haunted. And then Andy comes in and they end up doing a little dance together. It's going to get awkward real fast.
你是个聪明人。向内心深处去寻找汇报总结吧。汉娜可不买账。她才不买账。与此同时，在厨房里，我们要开启德怀特和安迪都在某种程度上调戏艾琳的故事线。德怀特做了件怪事，他拿办公室闹鬼来逗她。然后安迪进来了，他们最后还一起跳了一小段舞。这很快就会变得尴尬起来。
It really is. What happened to their bromance? It's already being tested. I know. Jenna, you know, like when you make a personal call and you know you need to make a personal call, but, you know, other people can overhear you. So you try to practice some form of etiquette in that phone call or speak in code a little bit. Mm-hmm. Yeah.
确实如此。他们的兄弟情怎么了？已经经受考验了。我知道。珍娜，你知道的，就像当你打私人电话时，你知道你需要打一个私人电话，但是，你知道的，别人能听到。所以你尽量在电话里讲究点礼仪，或者稍微用暗号说话。嗯哼。是的。
That's going to be happening at the Michael Scott Paper Company. It sure is. And there is a joke right off the bat that was so funny to me where Ryan is making plans for the weekend. And then he says, yeah, she's like a New York six, but in Scranton, she's a seven. And then he says, and my boss is my old boss, which makes it very clear that the Scranton seven is Pam. Yeah. New York six. And they cut to you and your face as you realize it is so great.
迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司就要上演这一幕了。确实如此。而且一开始就有一个笑话让我觉得超级好笑，瑞恩在计划周末。然后他说，是的，她就像是纽约的6分女，但在斯克兰顿，她就是个7分。然后他说，而且我的老板是我以前的老板，这使得斯克兰顿的7分女很明显就是帕姆。是的。纽约的6分。镜头切到你，当你意识到时的表情真是太棒了。
Justin said he felt like this was one of those amazing moments where the joke came before the setup. Yes. And paid off in this amazing way. The whole thing is such a smart joke. It's so well crafted. It made me laugh. I absolutely loved it. So I think we should stay down here in Michael Scott Paper Company and discuss the next thing that's going to happen, which is Ryan watching a video online instead of making the copies that Michael has requested.
贾斯汀说他觉得这是那些绝妙的时刻之一，笑话比铺垫先出现。是的。并以这种绝妙的方式得到回报。整段内容都是个绝妙的笑话。制作得太精良了。把我逗笑了。我绝对太喜欢了。所以我觉得我们应该留在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司这里，讨论接下来要发生的事情，那就是瑞恩没有去做迈克尔要求的复印，而是在网上看视频。
Yes. In 10 minutes, seven seconds, you can see the video that Ryan is watching. It was actually a local commercial in Alabama that became very popular on YouTube. And I want to tell you a little bit about it. So this went viral in 2006. A man named Sammy Stevens created and wrote and performed a jingle for his Montgomery, Alabama business. It was a flea market. Oh, yeah.
是的。在10分零7秒时，你可以看到瑞恩正在看的视频。这实际上是阿拉巴马州的一个本地广告，在YouTube上非常受欢迎。我想跟你们多讲一点。所以这个视频在2006年病毒式传播了。一个名叫萨米·斯蒂芬斯的人为他在阿拉巴马州蒙哥马利的生意创作、编写并演唱了一首广告歌。那是一个跳蚤市场。哦，是的。
And he did his own commercial. And it went viral. Over 12 million people have watched this video. Of course, it went viral before YouTube was kind of YouTube, right? And it wasn't monetized. So he has said in interviews, he didn't make any money off that, but it really took off. And Ellen DeGeneres had him on as a guest. Really?
他拍了自己的广告。然后它就火了。超过1200万人观看了这个视频。当然，它病毒式传播的时候YouTube还不是那种意义上的YouTube，对吧？而且它没有变现。所以在采访中他说过，他没有从中赚到任何钱，但它确实腾飞了。艾伦·德杰尼勒斯还邀请他作为嘉宾上节目。真的吗？
Uh-huh. The flea market is no longer in business, but Sammy is still writing commercial campaigns and performing. He has appearances on TV and a radio show. And I found Sammy on Instagram, he's at the real Sammy Stevens, S-T-E-P-H-E-N-S. Something I love about our show is that we were always working in these pop culture topical moments because that's what people do. That's what you would do is watch this YouTube video that was very popular while you were at work. It makes total sense to me.
嗯哼。那个跳蚤市场已经不营业了，但萨米仍在撰写广告活动文案并进行表演。他上过电视节目和广播节目。我在Instagram上找到了萨米，他的账号是真实的萨米斯蒂芬斯，S-T-E-P-H-E-N-S。我喜欢我们这部剧的一点是，我们总是把这些流行文化的实时热点融入其中，因为人们就是会那样做。你会做的就是趁上班时看这个非常受欢迎的YouTube视频。这对我来说完全合情合理。
Yeah. And you would show all your coworkers. It's actually something that would happen on our set. As we've shared, Oscar had the only working computer with sound and we would all huddle around his computer and watch videos. Well, at seven minutes and five seconds at the very top of the scene, you can see something sitting next to Ryan in the little poker chip. Catty? Yeah. Because we're sitting at a poker table, which is amazing.
是的。而且你会把视频展示给所有的同事。这其实也是我们片场经常发生的事。正如我们分享过的，奥斯卡拥有唯一一台带声音的正常工作电脑，我们都会挤在他的电脑周围看视频。好吧，在7分05秒时，就在场景的最上方，你可以看到一个东西正挨着瑞恩放在那个小扑克筹码盒旁边。猫砂盆？是的。因为我们坐在扑克桌旁，太神奇了。
It is an inhaler. Yes. This was a whole deleted runner. Yes. That Ryan uses an inhaler and he and Pam even get in a fight at one point and she steals his inhaler. Well, because Michael, he hands it to Michael for Michael to use and she's like, wait, that might be bad for him. Yeah. It's a whole thing.
是个吸入器。是的。这是一个被删掉的完整副线情节。是的。瑞恩使用了吸入器，他和帕姆甚至还在某个时候吵了一架，帕姆偷了他的吸入器。好吧，因为迈克尔，他把它递给迈克尔用，而帕姆就说，等等，这对可能他不好。是的。这是一整段情节。
It ended up getting cut, but that's why there is this inhaler and you can spot it throughout the episode sitting next to the laptop. There is also a fantastic shot at seven minutes, 36 seconds of all the clocks on the wall. I think we have to talk about them. There is a clock for Paris, London, Beijing and the USA. According to Jean and Lee and Justin, the USA clock was set to Scranton, but all the other clocks were set to the time interval between those cities and Los Angeles. And they caught this error halfway through the episode and they were just like, ah, we can't change it now. We have to just leave it. Oh, we got a lot of mail about those clocks, Angela.
最后被剪掉了，但这就是为什么会有这个吸入器，你可以在整集的这个场景中看到它放在笔记本电脑旁边。在7分36秒时，还有一个精彩的镜头，拍的是墙上的所有时钟。我觉得我们必须聊聊它们。墙上有巴黎、伦敦、北京和美国的时钟。根据简、李和贾斯汀的说法，美国时钟设置为斯克兰顿时间，但所有其他时钟都设置为这些城市与洛杉矶之间的时间差。他们在一集拍到一半时发现了这个错误，然后他们的反应就是，啊，我们现在改不了了。只能就这么留着。哦，我们收到了很多关于这些时钟的邮件，安吉拉。
I'm very glad that you brought it up. People will feel very satisfied because that has been spotted. You know, also in this scene, there is this very subtle thing that happens between Ryan and Pam that makes me laugh. They're discussing who should make the copies and Ryan says, you're just so good at it. You should do it, Pam. And she's like, you're saying that what I'm good at is pressing a big green button. And he's kind of like, listen, I don't judge what we're good at. Yeah, he's like, why is it insulting to say that you're good at something?
我很高兴你提到了这一点。大家会觉得很满足，因为这个穿帮已经被发现了。你知道，在这个场景中，瑞恩和帕姆之间还有一件非常微妙的事情发生，让我觉得很好笑。他们在讨论谁应该去复印，瑞恩说，你太擅长这个了。你应该去，帕姆。而帕姆的反应是，你的意思是我的长处就是按一个巨大的绿按钮？而瑞恩的反应有点像是，听着，我不对我们擅长的事做评判。是的，他就像是，说你擅长某事怎么就成侮辱了？
Yeah. So this reminded me of this very funny back and forth that my husband and I have had. Because I always say that Lee makes the best coffee in the morning and the best eggs. And I guess I'm very complimentary about it. I'm always like, these are the best eggs. This is the best coffee. So about like five years into our marriage, Lee says to me, do I really make the best eggs? Five years?
是的。所以这让我想到了我和我丈夫之间发生的一段非常搞笑的来回对话。因为我总是说李早上做的咖啡最好，煎蛋也最好。我想我对此赞不绝口。我总是说，这是最好的煎蛋。这是最好的咖啡。所以在我们结婚大约五年后，李对我说，我做的真的是最好的煎蛋吗？五年？
Yeah. He's been holding on to that. He says, do I really make the best coffee and the best eggs? Or is it just that you don't want to make them? And I was like, what? And he said, I mean, how hard is it to make good coffee and eggs really? Oh, no. I feel like maybe you're just complimenting my coffee and eggs so that I make you coffee
是的。他把这事记了这么久。他说，我真的是在做最好的咖啡和最好的煎蛋吗？还是其实只是因为你不想做？我当时就想，什么？他说，我是说，做好咖啡和煎蛋到底能有多难？哦，不。我觉得也许你只是在称赞我的咖啡和煎蛋，这样我就可以天天给你做咖啡
and eggs every day. And I was like, no, they really are superior. I swear it's better coffee than I make. I mean, that we could prove because there were some mornings when I made the coffee and Lee was like, oh yeah, that's not great. But Lee doesn't eat eggs. I eat eggs in the morning and he would always make me my eggs. But it's the truth, babe.
和煎蛋了。而我的反应是，不，它们真的是无可挑剔的。我发誓这比我自己做的咖啡好喝。我是说，这一点我们可以证明，因为确实有些早晨是我煮的咖啡，然后李就会说，哦，好吧，这不太行。但李不吃鸡蛋。我早上吃鸡蛋，他总是会给我做鸡蛋。但这是真的，宝贝。
Lee, you make the best coffee and eggs. You just do. Lee, I've traveled only a handful of times with your wife. I know you have traveled with her many, many times. And I know that this woman does not lie about food or beverage. Thank you. She is completely earnest when she likes something and when she doesn't, you're going to know about it. That's the thing.
李，你做的咖啡和煎蛋就是最好的。你就是做得最好。李，我和你妻子一起旅行过好几次。我知道你和她一起旅行过很多很多次。而且我知道这个女人绝不会在食物或饮料上撒谎。谢谢你。当她喜欢某样东西时她是完全真诚的，而当她不喜欢时，你绝对会看出来的。就是这样。
I'm not going to eat mediocre eggs for five years just because someone else made them for me. If I really believed I could make better eggs, I'd be making my own eggs. Well, once again, while people are talking in Michael Scott Paper Company, you hear someone in the bathroom. Yeah, you hear their voice through the ceiling. You hear them peeing. We had a fan question from Afrin R in the scene where Michael, Pam and Ryan are in their small new office and we hear a male voice talking on his phone in the bathroom.
我才不会仅仅因为别人帮我做，就连续五年吃味道平平的鸡蛋。如果我真的相信自己能做出更好的鸡蛋，我就会自己做鸡蛋了。好吧，又一次，当人们在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司说话时，你能听到卫生间里有人。是的，你能通过天花板听到他们的声音。你能听到他们在撒尿。我们收到来自阿夫林·R的粉丝提问：在迈克尔、帕姆和瑞恩在他们狭小的新办公室里的那个场景中，我们听到一个男的声音在卫生间里打电话。
Whose voice is it? It sounds like Toby, but the conversation made me doubt it. It was Toby. Paul did the voice. Now on the commentary, I think Jean and Lee joked that they made Paul sit up in the ceiling tiles to do his lines. But that is not true. He was actually just off camera. He was not in the ceiling.
那是谁的声音？听起来像托比，但那段对话让我产生了怀疑。那是托比。保罗配的音。现在在评论音轨中，简和李开玩笑说他们让保罗坐在天花板瓷砖上去念台词。但那不是真的。他其实只是在镜头外。他不在天花板里。
They added all the effects and posts to make it sound like he was in the bathroom above us, including like all the peeing sounds. But it really sounds like he's above you. I mean, I was so sold on that. Yeah. No, he was not. He was just off camera. But incidentally, I would like to point out that our sound team was nominated for an Emmy for Outstanding Sound Mixing for a Comedy or Drama Series Half Hour for this episode.
他们在后期制作中添加了所有的音效，让他听起来就像在我们头顶的卫生间里一样，包括所有的尿尿声。但听起来真的很像他在你头顶。我是说，我当时深信不疑。是的。不，他没有。他只是在镜头外。不过顺便指出，我想要强调的是，我们的音效团队凭借这一集获得了艾美奖喜剧或剧情类半小时剧集杰出音效混合奖的提名。
Well, they deserve it. I know. They really sounded like he was up there. And all the flushing and everything. Well, Michael's going to call his mom and talk in code. Jenna, much in the way that you and I talk in code, he's really bad at it. It's so obvious. It's so obvious.
好吧，他们实至名归。我知道。听起来真的就像他在上面一样。还有所有的冲水声以及其他声音。好吧，迈克尔要给他妈妈打电话并用暗号说话。珍娜，就像你和我用暗号说话一样，他这方面实在太差劲了。太明显了。太明显了。
He says, Mom, they're getting on my nerves, R thinks he's too good to be here and P is not as much fun without Jim. And then he's like, Mom, I got to go. P's being a giant B. This is us, lady. Well, this whole thing is going to end with Pam and Ryan bickering over the computer. I mean, they get in a huge fight over who gets to use it. And at eight minutes and 20 seconds at the end of this scene, the camera pushes in on Michael. He's standing in front of the whiteboard and written on the whiteboard is a quote that says, you miss 100% of the shots you don't take.
他说，妈，他们真让我心烦，R觉得自己了不起不该呆这儿，而且P没有吉姆在身边就没那么好玩了。然后他说，妈，我得挂了。P是个巨大的碧池。这就是我们，女士们。好吧，整段剧情最后以帕姆和瑞恩为了一台电脑争吵而告终。我是说，他们为了谁能用电脑大吵了一架。在8分20秒，也就是这个场景结束时，镜头推进对准了迈克尔。他站在白板前，白板上写着一句名言：你错失了100%你没有射出的球。
Wayne Gretzky, Michael Scott. As if Wayne Gretzky is part of the quote. Yes. Right. He's quoting himself quoting Wayne Gretzky. Justin Spitzer wrote that joke. Gene and Lee both brought it up saying it was one of their favorite parts of the episode. Like, I see that meme all the time.
韦恩·格雷茨基，迈克尔·斯科特。就好像韦恩·格雷茨基是这句话的一部分。是的。对吧。他在引用自己引用韦恩·格雷茨基的话。贾斯汀·斯皮策写了这个笑话。简和李都提到了这一点，说这是他们最喜欢这一集的桥段之一。就像，我经常看到那个表情包。
Oh, yeah. It's so brilliant. If you Google Wayne Gretzky's quote, a Michael Scott version with his picture comes up. It's crazy. Well, why don't we take a break? When we come back, we still have to discuss the pancake luncheon and Dwight and Andy's rivalry and Jim maybe finally figuring out what a rundown is. And also a scene where maybe Jim has disappeared. Where has he gone?
哦，是的。太绝了。如果你谷歌韦恩·格雷茨基的名言，就会跳出带有迈克尔·斯科特照片的版本。太疯狂了。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来，我们还要讨论煎饼午宴、德怀特和安迪的竞争，以及吉姆可能终于弄清楚什么是汇报总结了。还有一个场景，也许吉姆消失了。他去哪儿了？
I might have the answer. Oh, wow. Oh, I also have a sunglasses thing. Oh, and I do too. There's so much to come back for. We're back. Dwight is going to approach Andy about his obvious attraction to Aaron in only a way that Dwight would about tingly feelings and blood flow to places. Yes.
我可能有答案。哦，哇。哦，我还有个关于太阳镜的事要说。哦，我也有。还有好多内容等着我们回来呢。我们回来了。德怀特要去找安迪，谈论他明显对艾琳产生的吸引力，用的却只有德怀特才会用的那种关于酥麻感觉和血液循环到各处的方式。是的。
But he also confesses that he has his own feelings for Aaron. And they sort of talk about like, no, no, no, I don't want to get in your way and vice versa. I want you to note at nine minutes, 28 seconds while Dwight and Andy are talking, Aaron is in the background directly in the middle of these two guys. Oh, I'm sure that was on purpose. Oh, it was. Ian and Lee said that was intentional. They said they did this as many times as they could in this episode because it is a story about a woman coming between two guys. I really loved Leslie's look in the background as well. There's a lot to see in the background of the scene.
但他也坦白了自己对艾琳也有感觉。他们有点像是在说，不，不，不，我不想挡你的路，反之亦然。我希望你们注意在9分28秒，当德怀特和安迪在说话时，艾琳就在背景里，正好在这两个家伙的正中间。哦，我敢说那是故意的。哦，绝对是。简和李说那是刻意的。他们说他们在这一集里尽可能多地这么做，因为这是一个关于一个女人夹在两个男人中间的故事。我很喜欢莱斯利在背景里的表情。这个场景的背景里有很多看点。
That's pretty great. And there's also someone missing in the background of the scene. Where is Jim? I can tell you where he was. Where was he? They shared in the commentary that John had to leave early to be on The Tonight Show. Oh my gosh. Well, you know, we were rapidly approaching our 100th episode of The Office, which is going to be Company Picnic, the finale of season five.
那真是太棒了。而且这个场景的背景里还少了一个人。吉姆在哪里？我可以告诉你他在哪儿。他在哪儿？他们在评论音轨中分享说，约翰必须提前离开去录制《今夜秀》。哦，天哪。好吧，你知道的，我们正在迅速接近《办公室》的第100集，也就是第五季大结局《公司野餐》。
And we were starting to do a lot of press and promotion for that. I saw on the call sheets that after work on Thursday of this week, me and John and Rain stayed after work and we shot some syndicated promos. Oh, yeah. I found some old emails that a few of us did a satellite media tour as well. I bet, yeah. I always got roped in for those and they started it four in the morning because you do east coast to west coast. We were very excited. We were happy to do it.
我们当时开始为那个做大量的宣传和推广。我在通告单上看到，这周四下班后，我和约翰还有雷恩留下来加班，拍了一些联合网播的宣传片。哦，是的。我翻到了一些旧邮件，我们当中有几个人还参加了卫星媒体巡回宣传。我敢说，是的。我总是被拉去参加那些，他们早上四点就开始，因为你要从东海岸连线到西海岸。我们当时非常兴奋。我们很乐意去做。
We were team players. I was always really proud of our group effort for the show. Well, Jim is going to reappear pretty quickly because he's asking Oscar what the rundown is, right? He's gone over to the accounting nook much the way that Michael used to do. He would go ask Oscar what something meant and now Jim is doing it. I mean, Oscar's kind of the smartest guy in the office. Jenna, I love that you said that because Justin Spitzer said this in the commentary. He joked that Oscar was the voice of the writers.
我们很有团队精神。我一直为我们团队为这部剧付出的共同努力感到骄傲。好吧，吉姆很快就会重新出现，因为他在问奥斯卡什么是汇报总结，对吧？他走到会计角，就像迈克尔以前那样。他会去问奥斯卡某个词是什么意思，现在轮到吉姆这么做了。我是说，奥斯卡可以说是办公室里最聪明的人。珍娜，我很高兴你这么说，因为贾斯汀·斯皮策在评论音轨里也提到了这点。他开玩笑说奥斯卡就是编剧们的嘴替。
He's the smartest guy who's always judging everyone. Yeah, 100%. But Oscar says, why don't you just ask him? Just ask Charles what the rundown is. So there was a deleted scene where Jim actually took Oscar's advice. What? Yeah, you've got to hear it. You have a second?
他是那个总是评判每个人的最聪明的人。是的，百分之百。但奥斯卡说，你为什么不直接问他？直接去问查尔斯什么是汇报总结。所以有一个被删掉的场景，吉姆真的采纳了奥斯卡的建议。什么？是的，你得听听这个。你有空吗？
What is it, Jim? It's about the rundown. Jim, God, this rundown is taking more of my time than if I did it myself. What? What is the question now? What's a rundown? Is this one of your pranks? Huh?
怎么了，吉姆？是关于汇报总结的事。吉姆，天哪，这个汇报总结占用的时间比我自己做还要多。什么？现在又有什么问题？什么是汇报总结？这是你们的恶作剧之一吗？啊？
Yep. Boom. Jim, I don't have time. I know. All right, I'm going to get you that rundown. Just get it to me, Jim. Right now. I'm going to go out and find it.
是的。轰。吉姆，我没时间。我知道。好吧，我会把那个汇报总结给你。马上把它交给我，吉姆。立刻。我要出去把它找出来。
Oh, my gosh. Isn't that amazing? And I love that Charles clearly knows that Jim's the prankster, which he probably just add that to the list of things he doesn't like about Jim. But Jim actually asked him and then bailed. I bet that was a really funny scene. I wish that had stayed in. It was great.
哦，天哪。是不是太棒了？而且我喜欢查尔斯很清楚吉姆是个恶作剧大王，他大概只是把这加到了他不喜欢吉姆的事情清单里。但吉姆居然真的去问了他，然后又临阵脱逃了。我敢说那一定是个非常搞笑的场景。我真希望这个片段能保留下来。太棒了。
There was so much awkward. Just long pauses. Ugh. Well, back downstairs, Michael determines that there are office spaces too small. He says that the solution is for Pam and Ryan to each choose a corner. Pam suggests they work from home. Ryan suggests Michael fire whichever of them has less education.
有那么多尴尬的时刻。长久的停顿。呃。好吧，回到楼下，迈克尔判定办公空间实在太小了。他说解决办法是让帕姆和瑞恩各选一个角落。帕姆建议他们在家办公。瑞恩建议迈克尔开除他们俩中学历较低的那个人。
There's a little bit of that passive aggressive. But Michael is like, no, my corner idea is what it is. I want you to know there was a talking head in the script where Michael says that he negotiated a seven year lease on this space. No. No. But it gets worse. He says originally Billy started at three years.
有点那种被动攻击的意思。但迈克尔的反应是，不，我的角落创意就是这样。我想让你们知道，剧本里其实有一段单人访谈，迈克尔在里面说他为这个空间签了七年的租约。不。不会吧。但更糟糕的是。他说比尔原本只签了三年。
Michael countered with seven. Oh, Michael. And then Michael says I should have said 10. So this is going to be their space for seven years. Oh my gosh. Justin pointed out something really funny. He was like, you know, when Michael says there are four corners in this room and you guys kind of looked to camera like, yeah, idiot.
迈克尔还价到七年。哦，迈克尔。然后迈克尔说我当时应该说十年的。所以这将是他们七年的空间。哦，天哪。贾斯汀指出了一个超级搞笑的地方。他说，你知道的，当迈克尔说这个房间里有四个角落时，你们俩的表情有点像，废话，白痴。
Actually, there were more than four. There were because there was some like weird. Yeah. Well, Pam is going to retreat to her corner. By the way, her corner is next to the sewage pipe and the shower facing a wall. You think it can't get worse. Ryan's corner is like behind a plant. It's actually kind of the nicest corner really.
其实不止四个。确实有更多，因为有一些奇怪的……是的。好吧，帕姆要退守到她的角落了。顺便说一句，她的角落紧挨着污水管和淋浴间，面对着一面墙。你以为情况不能更糟了。瑞恩的角落就像是在一株植物后面。实际上真的是个相当不错的角落。
But things are going to get worse for Pam because Michael says that's his corner because he can't work in the same corner that he relaxes in. Right. So she's like, which one's mine? And he says yours is the one over there by the copier. Oh, we had a fan catch at 12 minutes one second. And it's a great continuity catch. It's very subtle.
但帕姆的处境要更糟了，因为迈克尔说那是他的角落，因为他不能在他放松的同一个角落里工作。对。所以她的反应是，哪个是我的？他说你的是那边复印机旁边的那个。哦，我们在12分零1秒发现了一个粉丝捉虫。这是一个很棒的连戏穿帮。非常微妙。
So hats off to Tatiana V who says when Pam goes to sit in her corner, she takes a small black object with her. You can see her holding it in her lap as the camera swings back and forth from her and Michael. But right before she gets up to leave, it has disappeared from her hands because Pam is now holding the arms of her chair. What is it? That's what she wanted to know. It was Pam's flip phone.
所以向塔蒂亚娜·V致敬，她说当帕姆去她的角落坐下时，她随身带了一个黑色的微小物体。当镜头在帕姆和迈克尔之间来回摇动时，你可以看到她把它拿在膝盖上。但在她起身离开之前，它从她手里消失了，因为帕姆现在正抓着椅子的扶手。那是什么？这就是她想知道的。那是帕姆的翻盖手机。
Pam grabs her flip phone off of the poker table, but clearly I didn't do it in every take because it does just vanish. I miss my flip phone. You do? I do. And I miss the little antenna it had and how I would close the antenna with my chin. I'd like shove it into my chin. It did feel fun.
帕姆从扑克桌上抓起她的翻盖手机，但显然我不是在每个镜头里都这么做了，所以它确实凭空消失了。我怀念我的翻盖手机。是吗？我怀念。而且我怀念它上面的小天线，以及我是怎么用下巴把天线合上的。我喜欢把它戳进下巴里。感觉挺好玩的。
I loved it. The flip phone. Yeah. Well, you know, Samsung has a new flip phone thing. You flip it open and it becomes like a big screen. Have you seen the commercials for it? I will never be able to figure it out. There's too many moving parts.
我太喜欢了。翻盖手机。是的。好吧，你知道的，三星有一款新的翻盖手机。你把它翻开，它就变成了一个大屏幕。你看到它的广告了吗？我这辈子也搞不懂这玩意儿。里面移动的零件太多了。
I know, but it looks cool in the commercials. It really does, Samsung. You know what I don't miss about my flip phone, lady? What? I don't miss the texting where you had to play A, A, B, B, C, C, A, D, E, E. Like you had to click, click, click. Yeah. Listen, all of this business with Ryan and the Corners, Pam's going to leave.
我知道，但在广告里看起来很酷。确实挺酷的，三星。你知道我对我的翻盖手机有什么不怀念的吗，女士？什么？我不怀念那种必须按A、A、B、B、C、C、A、D、E、E的打字方式。就像你必须不停地按、按、按。听着，所有关于瑞恩和角落的事情，帕姆要离开了。
She goes upstairs and she asks Charles for her old job back. She doesn't consult her fiance. Not that she needs to consult him, but you know what I mean? You would think she'd loop him in. You'd think she'd like say, Jim, I'm going to ask for her. I'm going to ask for my job back. No. But she didn't consult him when she quit and she's not going to consult him now.
她上楼去找查尔斯要求要回原来的工作。她没有和未婚夫商量。倒不是说她非得跟他商量，但你知道我的意思吧？你会觉得她应该让他知情。你以为她会说，吉姆，我要去申请。我要把工作要回来。没有。但她辞职时没有跟他商量，现在她也不会跟他商量。
She's desperate. She doesn't have time for that conversation. No. Well, Charles says the position has been filled. She says maybe a sales job, maybe a job as his personal assistant, personal shopper. Nope. No dice. So Justin talked about several different alts in the scene where they had Charles be really
她绝望了。她没有时间进行那种对话。不。好吧，查尔斯说那个职位已经有人了。她说也许是个销售工作，也许是做他的私人助理、私人采购员？不。没戏。所以贾斯汀谈到了这个场景中的几种不同备选方案，他们曾让查尔斯对帕姆表现得非常
sort of abrupt with Pam and they dialed it back because it seemed too harsh. So he's just more indifferent. He's just more business. Yeah. Well, this was my only real one-on-one scene with Idris, except for when he sort of came in the first day, but that wasn't much of an exchange. I was so nervous. I was such a fan.
粗鲁，后来他们把这种态度调低了，因为显得太严厉了。所以他只是更加冷漠。他只是更加公事公办。是的。好吧，这是我和伊德里斯唯一真正的对手戏，除了他第一天来的时候那种，但那其实算不上什么交流。我当时太紧张了。我是他的超级粉丝。
And to be standing there with this actor that I admired so much because I was a huge fan of the wire. And he has such a patient, quiet power in his scenes. And he's such a pro. I mean, I was just, I think some of my nervousness as Pam was just my nervousness as Jenna performing with this person that I admired. Yeah. Word has clearly gotten out about the Michael Scott paper company being downstairs because
能和这位我如此钦佩的演员站在那里，因为我是《火线》的超级剧迷。他在镜头前有一种很有耐心、很安静的力量。而且他是个绝对的专业人士。我是说，我当时只是，我想我作为帕姆的一些紧张，其实就是我作为珍娜与这位我极为钦佩的人演对手戏时的紧张。是的。关于迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司搬到楼下的消息显然已经传出去了，因为
Phyllis and Stanley decided to go pop by and say, hi, we really know what it was. They were just snooping. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I would do the same thing. Are you kidding? Well, at the top of the scene, when Phyllis and Stanley poke their head in, I want you to notice that Michael is playing with the stapler, the stapler that we loved that none
菲利斯和斯坦利决定顺便过来打个招呼，嗨，我们真的很想知道是怎么回事。他们其实就是在八卦。哦，是的。是的。我也会这么做。开什么玩笑？好吧，在场景刚开始时，当菲利斯和斯坦利探头进来时，我想让你们注意到迈克尔正在玩订书机，就是那个我们爱不释手、谁都忍不住去玩的订书机。我们会在她的桌子上认真地装订文件。所以你觉得史蒂夫当时只是在玩他觉得很酷的订书机吗？因为我不知道该怎么解释这个订书机气压机制。好吧。下次我去你家时，你能把那个订书机给我看看吗？我真该把它带过来，因为你能听到声音。就像是，哇。
of us could keep our hands off of. We would seriously staple papers on her desk. So do you think Steve was just like playing with the stapler he thought was cool? Because I don't know how to explain this air pressure mechanism of the stapler. Okay. Next time I'm over at your house, will you just show me the stapler? I seriously should have brought it in because you can hear it. It's like, wow.
就像在你的手掌中拥有工业订书机的全部威力。你应该给它们拍广告。我真的应该。它们应该赞助我们。只需动动手指按一下。当你使用它时，它是一个如此惊人的工程奇迹，以至于你只想把看到的一切都订起来。好吧，天哪。
It's like having all the power of an industrial stapler with the palm of your hand. You should do commercials for them. I really should. They should sponsor us. It's just the push of your finger. And when you do it, it's such an engineering marvel that you just want to staple everything on your site. Well, good Lord.
我得见识一下这个订书机。也许我应该拍一段自己订东西的视频，你可以把它放进办公室里。我会的。交给我吧。我们都得见识一下。好的。我来拍。我需要把它握在手里。
I need to see the stapler. Maybe I should do a video of myself stapling things and you can put it in the office. I will. Give it to me. We all need to see it. Okay. I'll do it. I need to hold it in my hand.
我需要摸摸它。等一下。等一下。这话听起来不对劲。我刚开始顺着这个思路说下去时，我的反应就是，不，打住。哇。继续我们的节奏，女士们，是时候开启煎饼午宴了。迈克尔就在外面。
I need to touch it. Wait a second. Wait a second. That is what she said. The minute I started going down that road, I was like, no back up. Wow. Moving us along, lady, it is time to kick off this pancake luncheon. Michael is outside.
我得摸摸它。等一下。等一下。这话听着耳熟。我刚一顺着那个方向想，就觉得，不行，打住。哇。好了，女士们，我们继续吧，是时候开始煎饼午餐了。迈克尔在外面。
He is making square pancakes for nobody yet. Ryan is texting. I love that Michael's like, stop with the texting machine. So here we are, Jenna, at our second pair of sunglasses at 14 minutes 59 seconds. Oh, yes. I have the same time code. What do you want to say about these sunglasses? Wait, can we say it right at the same time?
他还没给任何人做方形煎饼。瑞安正在发短信。我太喜欢迈克尔那种“别搞什么发短信机器了”的语气了。所以，詹娜，我们在14分59秒迎来了我们的第二副太阳镜。哦，是的。我的时间码也是一样的。你对这副太阳镜有什么想说的吗？等等，我们能同时说出来吗？
It'll be jarbled, but let's see if it sounds the same. Okay. These sunglasses were inspired by Joaquin Phoenix's appearance on the David Letterman show. In 2009, when he was promoting, I'm still here. It was a very odd appearance. I watched that in real time, but it was all part of like a marketing ploy or something. He did this film and I guess he was trying to make us believe that he had actually switched
听起来会乱成一团，但我们看看是不是一样的。好吧。这副太阳镜的灵感来自杰昆·菲尼克斯在大卫·莱特曼秀上的亮相。那是2009年，当时他在宣传《我仍在这里》。那次亮相非常诡异。我是实时观看的，但这其实是某种营销噱头之类的。他拍了这部电影，我猜他是想让我们相信他真的换了
careers and it was sort of like an Andy Kaufman-esque thing. I took a screen grab. I did a side-by-side for you, lady, Joaquin Phoenix and Ryan, same sunglasses. Putting that in stories. They retail for about $400. What? For sunglasses? Yeah.
职业，这有点像安迪·考夫曼式的风格。我截了图。女士，我为你做了一个对比图，杰昆·菲尼克斯和瑞安戴着同款太阳镜。我会把它发到快拍里。这副眼镜零售价大约400美元。什么？太阳镜要400美元？对啊。
Are they crazy? Are they prescription? No. They're just fancy. That's nuts. I mean, if I bought that pair of sunglasses, I might as well just flush $400 down the toilet because I'm going to lose them in less than a year. I know some people like fancy sunglasses and listen, you do you, but I don't know.
他们疯了吗？是处方镜吗？不是。它们只是比较别致。太疯狂了。我的意思是，如果我买这副太阳镜，我还不如直接把400美元冲进马桶里，因为我不到一年就会弄丢它们。我知道有些人喜欢时髦的太阳镜，听着，你开心就好，但我不知道。
Three kids, sunglasses, soccer games, mine just get wrecked. I splurged on a pair of $200 prescription sunglasses. I had to have prescription sunglasses. Because I was doing the double glasses for so long, where you buy a giant pair of regular sunglasses that you put over your real glasses. I saw it, Jenna. You look like you need to live in like a Florida retirement community. I know.
三个孩子，太阳镜，足球比赛，我的眼镜总是被毁掉。我曾奢侈地买了一副200美元的处方太阳镜。我必须得配处方太阳镜。因为我戴了很久的双层眼镜，就是买一副巨大的普通太阳镜套在你真正的眼镜外面。我看到了，詹娜。你看上去就像需要住在佛罗里达州退休社区的人。我知道。
And you know what? I managed to keep those prescription sunglasses for almost two years. I lost them somewhere and now I'm back to double glasses. You know what we need? What? Josh says I need the chain on my glasses. Oh, I have a story about my mom. What happens?
你知道吗？我设法把那副处方太阳镜保留了将近两年。我不知把它在哪弄丢了，现在我又回到了双层眼镜时代。你知道我们需要什么吗？什么？乔什说我的眼镜需要配个链子。哦，我有一个关于我妈妈的故事。怎么了？
That's it, right? That's it. Your sexy days are over. If you put your glasses on a chain, I don't know. Well, my mom, we affectionately call her Lucy because when you go into a store with her, it's like you're shopping with Lucille Ball from I Love Lucy because she will manage to get tangled in or knock over any store display. I was going to say, does she knock things over or try to put too many chocolates in
就这样了吧？没错。你的性感日子结束了。如果你给眼镜配上链子，我不知道。好吧，我妈妈，我们亲切地叫她露西，因为当你和她一起走进商店时，就像你在和《我爱露西》里的露西尔·鲍尔一起购物一样，因为她总能被任何商店的陈列架缠住或者撞翻。我是想说，她是把东西撞翻了，还是试图把太多巧克力塞进
her mouth? So we were shopping with her and she had on her glasses around one of those chains, but it was winter. So she also had a scarf and she also had, I don't know, long necklaces, a purse, you know, cross-bodied. She goes to take off her cross-body purse. It yanks on her sunglasses chain. Elbows are flying.
嘴里？所以我们和她一起购物，她的眼镜上挂着那种链子，但当时是冬天。所以她还围着围巾，还戴着，我不知道，长项链、一个斜挎包，你知道的，斜背着的。她去脱斜挎包。包带猛地扯到了她的眼镜链。胳膊肘乱飞。
She takes down a whole display of earrings. Oh, no. My sister and I are like rushing in to like help her. She's tangled. She looks like a cat tangled in string and just displays are falling down. So whenever I think about putting my glasses on a chain, that memory comes back to me and I think that could be me. I could be that.
她撞倒了一整排耳环展示架。噢，不。我和姐姐连忙冲过去帮忙。她缠住了。她看起来就像一只被绳子缠住的猫，货架纷纷倒塌。所以每当我想把眼镜挂在链子上时，那个记忆就会浮现，我想那可能会是我。我可能会变成那样。
I could easily have done that. I could take down a display. You could take down a display. I saw you almost take out a few people on an airplane with a guitar. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, so I can't, I can't chain my glasses is the bottom line. Oh, well.
我绝对会做出那种事。我可能会撞倒一个陈列架。我看到你在飞机上差点用一把吉他把好几个人打倒。对啊。对啊。我是说，所以，归根结底，我不能给眼镜配链子。好吧。
I'm sorry. Okay. But we spent $400 on these glasses for the character of Ryan for this very subtle inside joke that clearly Ryan is a Joaquin Phoenix fan and probably saw that it's in character. He is the kind of guy who has to have the thing, the latest thing. Even though his mom is driving him to work. Yes. Exactly.
抱歉。好吧。但为了瑞安这个角色，我们在这些眼镜上花了400美元，为了这个非常微妙的内行笑话：显然瑞安是杰昆·菲尼克斯的粉丝，可能看过那期节目。他就是那种必须拥有最新潮东西的人。尽管他妈妈正开车送他去上班。没错。完全正确。
He's really not employed. Like he's not earning a paycheck. He isn't. He's going to get $400 sunglasses at 15 minutes, 10 seconds. Right as Pam is walking up, there's a great shot of some fake grocery bags. Oh, we got some fake bags. We got some fake bags and Jenna, you shared on the commentary something that jogged my memory, it took me back immediately to this day, you shared while you were filming this
他其实根本没有工作。他根本没有收入。他没有。他在15分10秒买400美元的太阳镜。就在帕姆走过来的时候，镜头给了一些假杂货袋一个很好的特写。哦，我们有一些假袋子。我们有一些假袋子，詹娜，你在幕后花絮中分享的一件事唤醒了我的记忆，让我立刻回到了那一天，你分享说，当你们在拍摄这个
parking lot scene, the paparazzi snuck on to our set. Oh my gosh, I remember that. Yes. We had a guy. So guys, we weren't on a big lot. We've shared that before. We didn't have security, you just drove in. You did.
停车场场景时，狗仔队偷偷溜到了我们的片场。哦，天哪，我记得那个。是的。我们有一个人。所以，伙计们，我们不在一个大型片场。我们以前分享过。我们没有保安，你直接开车进来就行。确实如此。
And after this day, we got a security guard and a little hut. Yeah. Yeah. He clearly staked us out, realized you could just drive right on the set, came right on and just started clicking pictures of the set, the parking lot, actors coming out of their trailers. They got one of Steve coming out of his trailer and it took us all a while to be like, oh, who's that guy?
在这天之后，我们才安排了一个保安和一个小岗亭。Yeah. 是的。他显然踩了点，发现你可以直接把车开进片场，然后就直接闯进来，开始对片场、停车场、从房车里走出来的演员狂拍一气。他们拍到了一张史蒂夫从房车里走出来的照片，我们花了很长时间才反应过来，哦，那个人是谁？
Oh my God. Oh, wait, wait, wait. No one knows that guy. Did I mention in the commentary why we think this happened finally after five seasons? No. John had started dating Emily Blunt. Oh no. Yeah.
哦，天哪。哦，等等，等等，等等。没人认识那家伙。我在评论里提过我们为什么在五季之后才终于发生这种事吗？没有。约翰开始和艾米莉·布朗特约会了。哦，不。是啊。
So that was sort of tabloid-y interesting until now, none of us did anything of tabloid interest basically. No. No. So I remember this because I was dating Lee at the time. He and I were starting to get serious and John started dating Emily and we became couple friends. You did.
所以这有点像小报八卦，直到现在，我们当中没有谁做过任何具有小报价值的事。没有。没有。所以我记得这个，因为当时我正在和李约会。我和他开始认真交往了，约翰也开始和艾米莉交往，我们成了双约会的朋友。确实如此。
You guys would like go and do things. We did. And the news finally broke that the two of them were dating one another. And I think that's why the paparazzi showed up. Maybe so. Because it was just sort of what five years in out of nowhere, oh, this guy wants pictures. Yes, exactly. But one other time we had paparazzi show up was when we were shooting on location for
你们会一起出去玩什么的。我们会的。然后他们俩正在交往的消息终于曝光了。我想这就是狗仔队出现的原因。也许吧。因为这就像是五年来的头一遭，突然之间，哦，这家伙想要拍照。是的，完全正确。但我们遇到狗仔队出现的另一次是在我们实地拍摄
Jim and Pam's wedding. Oh yeah. Well, that would have been a big- That was like a big show of us within the show. But for the most part, we didn't have any of that stuff. We didn't. Thankfully. Because there are just our little tucked away little studio.
吉姆和帕姆的婚礼时。哦，对。好吧，那可是一场大——那就像是我们在剧中的一场大制作。但大部分时候，我们根本没有遇到过这种事。我们没有。谢天谢地。因为我们只是个偏僻的小工作室。
I agree. I do think at one point the paparazzi got a shot of me leaving my trailer with like my empty lunch plate. And it is the most short laugh, it is just like the most unflattering photo of a person who has finished their lunch. This was years later, you guys, like the show had ended and I was vacationing and I was at a beach that I guess Maria Sharapova was at. And the paparazzi clearly showed up for her, but I was like, side dish.
我同意。我确实觉得有一次狗仔队拍到了我离开房车时拿着空午餐盘的照片。那真是最短命的笑料，那绝对是一个人吃完午饭后最难看的一张照片。那是多年以后了，伙计们，比如剧集已经结束了，我在度假，我去了玛丽亚·莎拉波娃好像也在的一个海滩。狗仔队显然是冲着她去的，但我就像是，配菜。
So they got the photos of her and then they snapped a few of me and it ended up in a tabloid magazine and I saw the picture of me and I was like, how do I send them a thank you? Was it a really good picture of you on vacation? In my bathing suit, I was like, I should thank someone. I would say that we could put these photos in our stories, but it's going to be like me, with the lunching out of my empty food plate and you vacationing in Mexico. I had just like been working out and I just want to sell someone. Thank you.
所以他们拍了她的照片，然后顺便抓拍了几张我的，最后这张照片登在了一家小报杂志上，我看到这张照片时心想，我该怎么给他们寄感谢信呢？你在度假时的照片真的很好看吗？穿着泳衣，我当时想，我该感谢某人。我本来想说我们可以把这些照片发到快拍里，但那大概会是我拿着空餐盘吃午饭的照片，还有你在墨西哥度假的照片。我刚健完身，我只是想跟某人炫耀一下。谢谢。
Thanks for getting that for me. Well, since we're on the subject, I will just give this one more anecdote. I really, really did not get photographed by the paparazzi ever and I still don't. In fact, one time I got in a car accident. I was rear-ended by the paparazzi who were chasing Christina Ricci and I had to get out of my car and we had to exchange all of our information. The guy never took my picture in the whole exchange. And then another time I was out to dinner with Andy Roddick and Brooklyn Decker.
谢谢你帮我拍下这个。好吧，既然聊到这个话题，我再分享一个轶事。我真的、真的从来没有被狗仔队拍过，现在也没有。事实上，有一次我遭遇了一场车祸。我被追逐克里斯蒂娜·里奇的狗仔队追尾了，我不得不下车，我们必须交换各自的信息。整个交涉过程中，那家伙一张我的照片都没拍。然后还有一次我和安迪·罗迪克以及布鲁克林·戴克出去吃晚饭。
No one took your picture. They swarmed them and then everyone was taking their picture. Someone said, hey, can you hold my camera? Yeah, they were almost like, could you get out of the way of the picture of the beautiful people, please? You two are messing up our shot of the glamour couple. That was truly our story. Even when I was in the proximity of people being photographed by the paparazzi, no one
没人给你拍照。他们蜂拥而上，然后每个人都在拍他们的照片。有人说，嘿，你能帮我拿一下相机吗？是的，他们几乎就像在说，请问你能从拍这些俊男美女的照片里让开吗？你们两个把我们拍魅力情侣的镜头给搞砸了。这真的是我们的故事。甚至当我身处被狗仔队拍照的人附近时，也没有人
cared. This is so true. So true. I'm grateful. Yeah, me too. And then Jim has completed his rundown, everybody. Huge news. He presents it to Charles.
在乎。千真万确。千真万确。我很感激。是的，我也是。然后吉姆完成了他的工作汇报，各位。重磅新闻。他把它呈交给查尔斯。
Charles doesn't even want to look at it. Charles is like just fax it to everyone on the distribution list. He is so annoyed with Jim that it took him all day to just compose a list. And Jim, once again, is like embarrassed and tries to make up this thing like, yeah, I was just going to see you and I had the same format. And also, now Jim is not even sure what the distribution list is. I know. Has Jim done his job before?
查尔斯甚至看都不想看一眼。查尔斯就像是直接把它发给分发名单上的每个人。他对吉姆感到非常恼火，吉姆花了一整天时间才整理出一份名单。而吉姆再次感到尴尬，并试图编造一些借口，比如，是的，我正要去找你，而且我用的是相同的格式。而且现在吉姆甚至不确定分发名单是什么。我知道。吉姆以前做过他的工作吗？
What is he doing all the time? I want you guys to know something. The shot of Jim faxing his dad, the distribution list, was the very first thing that Ellie shot on her very first day of work on the office. That was her first scene on the call sheet. And then the second scene that she shot that day was that scene from the very top of the show where her and Kelly go into Charles's office and they decide to name her Erin. Those are two good first scenes.
他整天都在干什么？我想让你们知道一件事。吉姆把分发名单传真给他爸爸的那个镜头，是艾莉在《办公室》第一天上班时拍的第一场镜头。那是通告单上的第一场戏。然后她那天拍的第二场戏就是剧集开头的那场戏，她和凯莉走进查尔斯办公室，决定给她起名叫艾琳。这两场是很好的第一场戏。
I would be so grateful if my first scene on a show was me just sitting at the desk in the background. Not speaking. Yes. Just getting a feel for the room. Yes. Yeah. Well, we are about to have a guest star alert.
如果我在剧中的第一场戏只是坐在背景的办公桌旁，我会非常感激的。不说话。是的。只是去感受一下片场的氛围。是的。好吧，我们马上要迎来客串明星警报了。
We are because Pam is chatting up a potential client. One person has come to the pancake luncheon. He seems slightly interested, maybe not really interested, slightly interested in Michael Scott Paper Company. You can't really tell. Well, Pam doesn't have a business card on her. So she's going to tear off a scrap of paper. She finds that poetic because, you know, they sell paper.
我们要迎来了，因为帕姆正在和一位潜在客户聊天。有一个人来参加煎饼午餐会了。他看起来有点兴趣，也许不是真的很感兴趣，对迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司有点兴趣。你真的很难看出来。好吧，帕姆身上没有名片。所以她要撕下一张废纸。她觉得这很有诗意，因为，你知道的，他们卖纸。
She's putting a spin on it. That potential client that Pam is talking to is named Patrick Losasso and he was Jean and Lee's boxing trainer. Yeah. I remember them taking boxing classes. They were really into it. Yeah. Well, that was really popular at the time.
她正在为此做点包装。帕姆正在交谈的那个潜在客户名叫帕特里克·洛萨索，他是让和李的拳击教练。是的。我记得他们上过拳击课。他们真的很喜欢。好吧，那在当时真的很流行。
It's still kind of popular, but it had a huge flourish around this time. I mean, people were getting those, what are those bags? That they hit. Cylinder bags. Well, clearly Jenna and I did not take any boxing classes. We get to see Creed and Meredith in this scene as well. And Meredith wants to take a bunch of extra pancakes and did you guys catch this? She said, for my kid.
现在其实也挺流行，但在那个时期它大受欢迎。我的意思是，人们都在买那些，那叫什么袋子？他们击打的袋子。圆柱形的沙袋。好吧，显然詹娜和我没有上过任何拳击课。我们在这一幕中也看到了克里德和梅雷迪思。梅雷迪思想拿一堆额外的煎饼，你们注意到了吗？她说，为了我的孩子。
Yeah. One kid, for my kid. For one kid. We've received a lot of mail about that, Angela, apparently in one of the webisodes. Meredith explains the mystery of the second kid. We've got to rewatch the webisodes. We really do. We should break down the webisodes.
对。一个孩子，为了我的孩子。为了一个孩子。我们收到了很多关于这事的邮件，安吉拉，显然在其中一集的网络短剧里。梅雷迪思解释了第二个孩子的谜团。我们得重温一下网络短剧。我们真的得看。我们应该剖析一下网络短剧。
We should add it to our rewatch. The webisodes. Absolutely. We must do this. Okay. We will do this. We will do this. Obviously, Meredith says that when she got divorced, her ex-husband got the good kid.
我们应该把它加入我们的重温计划中。网络短剧。绝对的。我们必须这么做。好吧。我们会这么做的。我们会这么做的。显然，梅雷迪思说过，当她离婚时，她的前夫拿走了那个好孩子。
And she got the other one. So there are two kids. Okay. We had a fan question from Alyssa, Ryan, and Madeline. They wanted to know, were those real pancakes at the brunch? They were real pancakes. No way. Phil Shea hired a food stylist who had a bunch of griddles set up in the warehouse and she
而她拿走了另一个。所以有两个孩子。好吧。我们收到了来自阿丽莎、瑞安和马德琳的粉丝提问。他们想知道，早午餐上的那些煎饼是真的吗？那是真的煎饼。不可能吧。菲尔·谢伊雇了一位食物造型师，她在仓库里摆了许多烤盘，她
made all of those square pancakes. I thought they were like fakey foam pancakes. No. They were real edible pancakes. I would have eaten one. I love pancakes. Well, you know, it is very hard to make a square pancake. Yeah.
做出了所有那些方形煎饼。我以为它们是那种假冒的泡沫煎饼呢。不是。它们是真正可食用的煎饼。我会吃一个的。我超爱煎饼。好吧，你知道的，做方形煎饼其实很难。对啊。
Do you have to have a special pan or something? It's really like what Michael did, where you have almost like a cookie cutter thing, but it is still incredibly difficult to do. Ainsley, our associate producer, who helps us prep our episodes, sent me a deep dive on why pancakes are round and why it is so difficult to make them any other shape. I will share with you. It is because gravity pulls on fluid uniformly. So when the dollop of batter hits the griddle at a right angle, it gets tugged down into
你必须得有一个特殊的锅之类的东西吗？这真的就像迈克尔做的那样，你几乎需要一个像曲奇模具一样的东西，但做起来依然极其困难。艾因斯利，我们的助理制片人，她帮我们筹备剧集，给我发了一篇关于为什么煎饼是圆的以及为什么把它们做成其他形状会如此困难的深度解析。我跟你们分享一下。这是因为重力对流体的拉力是均匀的。所以当一团面糊以直角落在烤盘上时，由于物理学家所说的圆柱对称性，它会被向下拉扯成
a round symmetrical shape due to what physicists call cylindrical symmetry. This means that its shape will not change if you rotate it around its axis. That is what cylindrical symmetry is. All directions except up and down are the same. Also, I guess, the scientific thing that is surface tension, whatever that is, is physics. That helps hold it in a perfect circle. We should do a science podcast. Clearly.
一个圆形的对称形状。这意味着如果你绕着它的轴旋转它，它的形状是不会改变的。这就是圆柱对称性。除了上下方向外，所有方向都是相同的。另外，我猜，表面张力这个科学概念，不管那是什么，就是物理学。它有助于将其保持在一个完美的圆圈中。我们应该做一个科学播客。显然。
Clearly. You know that. I'm good at it. I think that's physics. Is that the centrifugal, there's a pulling, and then there's a, you know what, gravity. I'm going to go back to gravity. Yeah. Mm-hmm.
显然。你知道的。我很擅长这个。我想那属于物理学。是离心力吗，有一种拉力，然后还有一种，你知道的，重力。我还是回归重力吧。好吧。嗯哼。
That is some reason why pancakes are round, thanks to some articles by Mental Floss and Quora.com. Truly, it is fascinating to me. I don't know how to retell that, and I don't even understand what you said, but I appreciate the science behind it. When you make a pancake, just know there's a lot of physics at work. Yeah. Mm-hmm.
多亏了Mental Floss和Quora.com的一些文章，这就是煎饼为什么是圆的一些原因。真的，这对我来说太迷人了。我不知道该怎么复述，我甚至听不懂你刚才说了什么，但我很感激背后的科学原理。当你做一个煎饼时，只要知道有很多物理学原理在起作用就行了。好吧。嗯哼。
I mean, listen, I think that if you memorized what I said, and you're making pancakes for your kids next time, and you just throw that out there, you're going to sound pretty smart. I'll get it wrong. They'll call me on it. You have to write it on your hand. I know. Or on a card. I need a cue card.
我是说，听着，如果你记住了我刚才说的话，下次你为孩子们做煎饼时，你只要把这些抛出来，你听起来就会非常聪明。我会说错的。他们会指出来的。你得把它写在手上。我知道。或者写在卡片上。我需要一张提示卡。
Which brings me to... Oh! Oh! Such a great scene. Andy and Dwight in the break room, Andy's playing banjo, and Dwight is playing guitar, and they are jamming to Take Me Home Country Road, as Erin looks on, impressed. Oh yeah, they're really trying to one-up each other in front of her. And she sings along.
这让我想到了……哦！哦！太棒的一幕了。安迪和德怀特在休息室里，安迪在弹班卓琴，德怀特在弹吉他，他们在即兴演奏《带我回故乡》，艾琳在一旁看着，印象深刻。哦，是的，他们真的在试图在她面前争奇斗艳。而且她还跟着唱。
Mm-hmm. It's amazing. We got so much fan mail about this. Abby Kay wanted to know, was any of this improvised because Erin looks genuinely shocked when they start singing, and then Jasper D wants to know, does Rain actually play the guitar in real life, or did he have to learn it just for this scene? Well, first of all, this was all planned. It was all scripted.
嗯哼。太棒了。我们收到了大量关于这幕的粉丝邮件。阿比·凯想知道，这其中有即兴发挥吗，因为当他们开始唱歌时，艾琳看起来真的很震惊，然后贾斯珀·D想知道，雷恩现实中真的会弹吉他吗，还是他为了这一幕特意去学的？好吧，首先，这一切都是计划好的。都是按剧本演的。
Mm-hmm. In fact, Randy Cordray told us that it cost $22,000 to license the song for this scene. Also, Rain does play guitar. He also plays the drums. And the recorder. And the recorder, which we know. And the bassoon. Oh my gosh, he plays a lot of instruments.
嗯哼。事实上，兰迪·科德雷告诉我们，为这一幕给这首歌授权花费了22,000美元。另外，雷恩确实会弹吉他。他还打鼓。还有竖笛。还有竖笛，我们都知道。还有巴松管。哦天哪，他会演奏好多乐器。
He can also juggle. He's a great juggler. He's like a Renaissance fear guy. He is. Didn't he go to clown school? I'm pretty sure he did. I'm pretty sure he did. I'm gonna say that sounds right.
他还会杂耍。他是个出色的杂耍艺人。他就像个文艺复兴时期的狂欢节艺人。他确实是。他没去过小丑学校吗？我敢肯定他去过。我敢肯定他去过。我只能说听起来是这样的。
Okay. Well, Ed really does play the banjo. In fact, Ed started a bluegrass band in college called The Lonesome Trio. And can play banjo guitar and piano, and these guys, they just practiced together at lunch on the day of the scene to get this right. Yeah. You know, when they were filming it, everything was going well. And then they got to the part where Rain had to sing, take me home country road in German.
好吧。埃德确实会弹班卓琴。事实上，埃德在大学里组建了一个名为“寂寞三人组”的蓝草乐队。而且会弹班卓琴、吉他和钢琴，这些家伙，他们在拍这场戏的那天午餐时间一起练习，为了把这首曲子练好。是的。你知道，当他们在拍摄时，一切都很顺利。然后他们到了雷恩必须用德语唱《带我回故乡》的部分。
Mm-hmm. And something about having to do it in German and keep the tune and play the guitar while Ed's playing. He was struggling a little bit. So Randy said they got him really big cue cards and they wrote out the German part of the lyrics phonetically. Mm-hmm. They had hired a translator to translate the song.
嗯哼。不知为什么，既要用德语唱，又要保持曲调，还要在埃德弹琴的同时弹吉他。他有点吃力。所以兰迪说他们给他准备了非常大的提示卡，把德语歌词按发音拼写了出来。嗯哼。他们雇了一位翻译来翻译这首歌。
Oh, yeah. He's really singing the lyrics in German. Yeah. They put these huge cue cards right behind Ellie's shoulder, just off camera. And I want you to know if you go to 17 minutes, 47 seconds, Rain, right in that moment, I see you look at the cue card. You see him check it? Yeah.
哦，是的。他真的是用德语唱歌词的。是的。他们把这些巨大的提示卡放在艾莉肩膀后面，就在镜头拍不到的地方。我想让你们知道，如果你快进到17分47秒，雷恩，就在那一刻，我看到你看了一眼提示卡。你看到他检查了吗？对。
Uh, I mean, that is hard. It's hard to sing a song, you know, in another language, but also it's a song you just learned on the guitar. Yeah. I remember one Christmas song I learned in Indonesian. Selamat Hari Natal, Selamat Hari Natal, Selamat Hari Natal, Dantah Un Baru. We wish you a merry Christmas. Nice.
呃，我是说，这太难了。用另一种语言唱歌很难，而且这还是一首你刚在吉ł上学会的歌。是的。我记得我学过一首印尼语的圣诞歌。Selamat Hari Natal, Selamat Hari Natal, Selamat Hari Natal, Dantah Un Baru. 我们祝你圣诞快乐。不错。
You guys know I grew up in Jakarta, but there were times when you would learn a very sort of Westernized song in a different language. Well, did you notice that when Rain is singing in English, he actually gets the lyrics a little wrong? Yeah. Yeah, he flipped it. He did. So the real lyrics are, country roads take me home, but Rain sings, take me home country
你们知道我在雅加达长大的，但有时你会用不同的语言学习那种非常西化的歌曲。好吧，你们有没有注意到，当雷恩用英语唱歌时，他其实把歌词唱错了一点？对。是的，他把它颠倒了。他确实颠倒了。所以真正的歌词是，乡间小路，带我回家，但雷恩唱的是，带我回家，乡间小路。
road. Right. Well, I just thought we had to hear this. Can we hear Ed playing the banjo and Rain playing the guitar? Take me home country road to the place I belong, West Virginia, Mount Mama, take me home country road, take it in there, road, take it in there, road, take it in there, road, take it in there. You have to stop. How fun is it to hear those guys play?
没错。好吧，我只是觉得我们必须听听这个。我们能听听埃德弹班卓琴和雷恩弹吉他吗？带我回到那乡间小路，去往我归属的地方，西弗吉尼亚，妈妈山，带我回到那乡间小路，把它带进去，路，把它带进去，路，把它带进去，路，把它带进去。你得停下来。听这俩人演奏有多好玩？
Well, I know they must have had so much fun doing that. I loved listening to it, because it made me just think of them in real life. Yeah. The only thing missing for me was Creed, because you know Creed would have just been jamming on his mandolin. I just loved that moment. One of the things I also loved was Justin said that, you know, this really showed the bromance, because while the beginning, they're trying to one up each other and they're playing
好吧，我知道他们做这事时肯定玩得很开心。我听得很开心，因为它让我想起了他们在现实生活中的样子。是的。对我来说唯一的遗憾是克里德不在，因为你知道克里德肯定会用他的曼陀林跟着即兴合奏。我太喜欢那个时刻了。我喜欢的其中一件事是，正如贾斯汀所说，（这首歌）真的展现了兄弟情深，因为虽然一开始他们试图争奇斗艳，他们在演奏
and they're playing over each other, it ends up in just a bromance, mutual admiration. And Aaron's not even there. She walks away and now they're just looking at each other, harmonizing and jamming out and they're back. Well, while I was researching this episode, I found this really cool quote from Ed, where he talked about Andy's banjo playing on the show. It's from an e-magazine article and here's what he said. He said, I'm happy to play my banjo at any opportunity I can get, but there's no real
而且在互相比拼，但最终它演变成了一种兄弟情、相互欣赏。而艾琳甚至都不在那里。她走开了，现在他们只是看着对方，彼此和声、即兴演奏，他们找回了状态。好吧，当我在研究这一集时，我发现了埃德的一句非常酷的名言，他谈到了安迪在剧中的班卓琴演奏。它来自一篇网络杂志的文章，他是这么说的。他说，只要有机会，我随时都乐意弹我的班卓琴，但对于安迪为什么会弹班卓琴，并没有真正的
explanation why Andy plays the banjo. It's so fun and weird, but he's a Connecticut preppy guy. How did he pick up a banjo? It's one of Andy's many mysteries, not all of which I even understand. But I love that Andy plays the banjo, but Ed is so right. Like I never thought, how or why does Andy know how to play the banjo? Yeah, it doesn't clock at all. And also that he could just pick up a sitar and play it.
解释。这很有趣也很奇怪，但他是个康涅狄格州的预科生。他是怎么学会弹班卓琴的？这是安迪的众多谜团之一，甚至连我自己都无法完全理解。但我喜欢安迪弹班卓琴，不过埃德说得太对了。就像我从来没想过，安迪怎么会或者为什么要学弹班卓琴？是的，这完全说不通。而且他还能随手拿起一把西塔尔琴弹奏。
You know, it's like he's so musically talented. I get the acapella side, but this banjo is so specific. It is. Well, sad to say the pancake brunch was a little bit of a wash. Yeah. Other than the one dude. I don't think anyone came. Creed and Meredith.
你知道，这就像他极具音乐天赋一样。阿卡贝拉清唱那一套我懂，但这个班卓琴实在是太具体了。确实如此。好吧，遗憾的是，煎饼早午餐有点泡汤了。对。除了那个小伙子。我觉得没人来。克里德和梅雷迪思。
That's it. Yeah. At 18 minutes, 22 seconds, we have a very sad shot of Michael and the wind is blowing the paper all over. Randy told me that we set up huge special effects fans to create this wind that it would make the whole thing feel even sadder if all these papers were blowing around and the table cloth was blowing in the wind. And then Jean told me that Randall, our cinematographer, spent almost an hour filming paper blowing
就这样。对。在18分22秒，我们看到了一个非常凄凉的镜头，迈克尔和风把纸吹得到处都是。兰迪告诉我，我们设置了巨大的特效风扇来制造这种风，如果所有的纸都在四处飞舞，桌布在风中飘扬，会让整件事感觉更加凄凉。然后简告诉我，我们的摄影指导兰德尔花了将近一个小时拍摄纸张在
across the parking lot, like sad shots of paper blowing, he said, we never used any of it. It's an hour of paper blowing footage. Yes. That would have gone into the closet of tapes somewhere. Which is now Michael Scott Paper Company. Well, now they're all really down in the dumps. They go back into their tiny closet office and you kind of feel like they're giving
停车场飞舞的镜头，比如纸张飞舞的悲伤镜头，他说，我们最后一点都没用上。那可是一个小时的纸张飞舞素材。是的。那些素材本该进到某个地方的磁带储藏室里的。现在那成了迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。好吧，现在他们都情绪极其低落。他们回到了他们狭小的储藏室办公室里，你多少会觉得他们要
up. And then the phone rings and Pam answers it. And guess what? It's Russell from the guy luncheon. He wants paper. He does. He places an order and Pam guarantees his satisfaction. She guarantees it.
放弃了。然后电话响了，帕姆接了电话。你猜怎么着？是单身汉午餐会上的拉塞尔。他要买纸。他真的要买。他下了一个订单，帕姆向他保证他一定会满意。她保证。
It is her guarantee. Pam has made her first sale. Not only the first sale of Michael Scott Paper Company, but her first sale, they're going to tack a dollar up to the wall. It's a huge celebration. Pam leaves with a spring in her step. Oh, yeah. She runs out, gives Jim a kiss in the parking lot.
这是她的保证。帕姆完成了她的第一笔销售。不仅是迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司的第一笔销售，也是她自己的第一笔销售，他们要在墙上钉上一美元。这是一个巨大的庆祝活动。帕姆迈着轻快的步伐离开了。哦，是的。她跑出去，在停车场给了吉姆一个吻。
This is an amazing day. Ryan's mom is there to pick him up. Sure. Ryan's mom was played by Cindy Drummond. And there was actually a scene that got cut from the very top of the show of her dropping him off at work and giving him a sack lunch. Cindy is an amazing actress. She's been in a ton of television comedy.
这真是神奇的一天。瑞安的妈妈来接他了。没错。瑞安的妈妈由辛辛·德拉蒙德饰演。其实原本在剧集开头有一场戏被剪掉了，那是她开车送他去上班并给他带了一个纸袋午餐。辛迪是一位出色的演员。她演过大量的电视喜剧。
Her scenes just got cut for time. It's really unfortunate because we were really lucky to have her on the show. I love that detail. Every time I see her pull up in her station wagon, I just love it. Well, the episode's going to end with Andy and Dwight. They're just in such a great mood. They're walking through the kitchen. Oscar and Angela are sitting there.
她的戏份只是因为时间关系被剪掉了。真的很遗憾，因为我们能请她来参演真的很幸运。我太喜欢那个细节了。每次看到她开着旅行车停下来，我都爱得不行。好吧，这一集将以安迪和德怀特结尾。他们的心情真是好极了。他们正穿过厨房。奥斯卡和安吉拉坐在那里。
Angela does a massive eye roll. And there was an Angela talking head that got deleted. Dwight and Andy? Friends. I mean, what do those two possibly have in common? She just takes a minute and she's like, what could they possibly have in common? And then looks at the camera like a little embarrassed. That was Michael Scott Paper Company.
安吉拉大大地翻了个白眼。而且原本还有一个被删掉的安吉拉的采访镜头。德怀特和安迪？朋友。我是说，这两人之间能有什么共同点？她停顿了一会儿，心想，他们俩到底能有什么共同点？然后有点尴尬地看着镜头。以上就是迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。
And next week is heavy competition, which happens to be Office Lady's 100th episode. I can't believe it. Yeah. I can't believe it. Driving into Eer Wolf today, I always call my mom on my drive and she said, well, how many have you done? She was like, are you almost done? I said, mom, we're coming up on 100.
而下周是激烈的竞争，这正好是《办公室女士》的第100集。我简直不敢相信。是的。我简直不敢相信。今天开车去Eer Wolf的路上，我总是在开车时给我妈打电话，她问我，你们已经录了多少集了？她问，你们快录完了吗？我说，妈，我们快到100集了。
She said, is that it? I said, no, we're halfway. Halfway there. All right. So we will see you next week for Office Lady's 100th episode heavy competition. Thank you so much for listening. Thank you guys. I know we just heard Dwight and Andy playing together, but I want to hear as we leave the
她说，就这？我说，不，我们才刚过半。走了一半路程了。好吧，那么我们下周见，收看《办公室女士》的第100集：激烈竞争。非常感谢大家的收听。谢谢大家。我知道我们刚刚听了德怀特和安迪的合奏，但在我们离开这集时，我想听听埃德的独奏，当作我们的道别。我永远听不够埃德弹班卓琴。哇。什么？
episode Ed solo, as we say goodbye. I can always listen to Ed play that banjo. Wow. What? Oh my God. You heard that. I'm so embarrassed. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
哦，天哪。你听到了。我太尴尬了。感谢收听《办公室女士》。
Office Ladies is produced by Eer Wolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubaco. The theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由Eer Wolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制片人是艾因斯利·布巴科。主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听《办公室女士》无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。在Stitcher Premium免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。